good good
morning colleagues um welcome to
legislative Administration um
representative Pearson can you lead us
in the pledge
absolutely I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all thank you uh a couple of bookkeeping
things you'll notice that we're in our
old double room here um but we are not
scheduled to be in it's it's not a
longlasting effect that we have going um
it will
be just for today I believe and we'll be
back to our um our scheduled single room
which I think is
203 um we share with house
transportation and I don't mind telling
you that I sat there yesterday and and
uh it's a little strange going back to
the single room that we've been used to
for years and years and years but I've
kind of grown accustomed to this double
room um at any rate that's uh item
number one item number two is the
scheduling that we have um nothing
changes on the schedule before you for
the 9 a.m. hearing and the 9:30 hearing
and the h CH 25 10:00
hearing what will change
is the next two um but I will be
addressing this again just before we
break for lunch um 1367 the prime
sponsor has reached out to me um he has
a scheduling conflict for
10:30 but it also happens that he and he
is a sole sponsor of the that bill uh
1367 but he also is handling House Bill
1096 that's scheduled this
afternoon so I have sent a note to him
and with courtesy um suggested that he
can um we can reschedule
1367 to either just before or just
after House Bill
1096 this
afternoon um
everyone get understand that little
tidbit um the next part is House Bill
1219 after I um put this schedule
together with uh our vice chair um this
Prime sponsor of 129 came and said she
wouldn't be able
to access her experts that need to
testify um for
today so she has asked if we can
reschedule that to a different day as
well um so we're looking at the schedule
now nothing has been scheduled but again
just before noon time I will um open and
recess 1219 to a date certain um
probably the first Wednesday in
February and then we'll just move right
into the afternoon um after lunchtime um
I'll be handing the gavel to our vice
chair um and um and all of the remaining
bills will be done much more smoothly
than the morning bills for that
reason um so with that uh unless there's
any questions on on the scheduling that
I just mentioned um seeing none um we'll
open the hearing on House Bill 1495 I
recognize the prime sponsor in the room
representative
gearheart um welcome to legislative
Administration thank you chairman thank
you committee for hearing this bill my
name is Jason Gard I represent
Northfield Franklin marac 25 so this
bill came
about from initially actually reading a
letter that Thomas Jefferson wrote to
James Madison in which he states that no
law can be permanent because no man is
permanent and he has a little
calculation where he figures about every
20 years all the laws should expire and
then be reintroduced or reapplied for if
they are needed the point being is we
need to figure out if the laws as far as
I'm concerned are in instituted to make
Society better safer so forth but if
they're not effective in doing so we
need to re-evaluate what's going on
because the repal process is pretty
cumbersome so as far as New Hampshire
goes this
bill would
dependent upon the percentage of the
general court that votes in favor give a
lifespan to a bill so here we go 51% to
64% the automatic repeal would happen
three years after its effective date if
the vote was 65% to 79% it would be
seven years and if it was
80% upwards it would be 10 years the
point being is if more people believe
the bill is necessary then it should
last a little bit longer to see how it
actually affects New Hampshire and
Society in general and then there's
another aspect to it towards the bottom
paragraph four where well number four
where you see that if aund registered
voters apply to the Secretary of State
to make sure they're actually really
registered voters then a bill for repal
repeal of a bill it'll go before the
committee that has standing over it and
then they will decide whether to send it
to the floor with a recommendation for
appeal so the concept being that the
Committees generally have a better
concept of these bills and if they're
being if they're efficacious or not and
can deal with them as such so I
just I think it's important for people
to especially younger people to feel
like they actually have a say in what's
going on and it's not just a bunch of
laws that have been on the books forever
that they have no connection with and
just really no feeling that you can
change it besides minor
let me back up I worry sometimes that we
try to edit and fix a bad Bill instead
of just letting it die and create
something new and figuring out where we
can go from here instead of just trying
to tweak the same thing that hasn't been
working and as Ron Paul said there's no
such thing as a failed government
program simply underfunded ones and I I
think that's kind of a major
problem so real quickly I just quote
from this letter that Thomas Jefferson
wrote
the Earth belongs in usfr which is the
right to use and profits of something
belong to another to the living that the
dead have neither power powers nor
rights over
it and he the letter actually is he was
in France at the time and the French
Revolution was kicking off but his main
concern was that if a government is able
to contract debts greater than the
current generation could pay off it
leads to the dogs of war being loosed as
it were and Perpetual War EMP ire
building and things we're all too
familiar with so that is why I
introduced it and I do understand that
there are some concerns with the
percentage basis aspect of it I just
didn't really know how else
to Institute the will of the people into
the lifespan of the bill I think that's
key I don't want to just have a
universal every Bill last or 10 years I
think it should vary depending on the
percentage of the representatives I
believe it's needed
so if there's any questions I definitely
welcome them I understand this is kind
of a
yes thank you all done
um I'm going to uh take a prerogative
and ask the first question sure um so
just for clarification you had said um
depending on how the general court voted
um but I'm seeing here that you mention
only the house Clerk and and how the
vote how the bill passed from the House
of Representatives yes um there's
nothing in here that I could see that
that um recognizes how the vote um
occurred in the Senate is that one in
one hand you mentioned general court and
the other you mentioned just the House
of Representatives so what what are you
thinking understood in my mind I think
of General Court the House of
Representatives I think it's closer to
the people I don't really think the
Senate has much of a connection with the
people no offense that was that was just
my clarification I saw rep Pearson's
hand first
um thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
presenting your your bill this
morning throughout the
rsas and it doesn't really matter which
chapter
there is a tremendous amount of
referencing as an ex you know and I
won't there's no need to give a specific
example but a lot of times what will
happen it it will reference another part
of
Statute not all of those things were
enacted at the same time so how would
you deal under this premise how would
you
deal
with a piece of Statute that references
something that has now
expired because law can't reference a
piece of statue that doesn't
exist I would leave it up to the
expertise of honorable chairmans like Mr
Hill and now and
specifically are you familiar with RSA
1 because the expiration of RSA 1 ends
the State of New
Hampshire okay okay so if we how do how
logistically would we go about
reenacting our existence when RSA 1
expires because it under this you you
leave no provision for the rare case of
something that must must be in
perpetuity well I believe that would be
a the percentage basis for automatic
repeal is for new legislation but for
current legislation that would fall
under
Roman numeral four which is the 100
registered voters so if we do have 100
registered voters that come forward and
say you know what I think it's time to
start over you know we're going to
change New Hampshire to another state
name or whatever then it would go before
the committee that would handle such
bill I don't even know what committee
would handle that but whatever it is and
then we would leave it up to
Representatives who represent the people
and the will at large to figure that
out
represent thank you Mr chairman good
morning good morning U thank you for
your testimony um where else in our
country is this happening is is this the
first piece of legislation anywhere in
our country to reference this type of
process as far as I understand but I
could be wrong I I the automatic repeal
or sunsetting of bills is not new that I
was actually doing some research on this
a little bit and in the 70s apparently
there was a major push to Sunset a lot
of federal legislation being most of the
major big agencies were Exempted you
know the normal thing like the Pentagon
Camp pass and a that you so um yeah I
believe this would be the
first thank you I'm going to hold
questions for a
while thank you um so I have another one
sure
um if um if we are dealing with um uh
concurrent bills or bills that that are
on the same
topic um okay how and and one passes
with an amendment um that people in the
house seem to want more than the one
without the amendment and and the
percentages change how would you handle
something like
that on line 18 is if an act is further
amended by another legislative session
the time until the perspective appeal
will follow the percentage of members
present voting ought to pass on the
further Amendment does that answer your
question or am I incorrect um no and and
it may be more that I um imprecisely
asked the
question but Suppose there are two
pieces of legislation in the same
session okay that that are Al along the
same lines um and and all that one does
is perhaps have an amendment and that
has for that reason had a higher um
support um but they but they handle the
same section of
law um how would we how would the clerk
how would any of us know which of these
bills are going to be repealed in three
years versus 10
years I would say we should ER on the
side of repealing
sooner in general I I I don't really
know if that would occur because each
bill would have its own repeal date so
you're saying two bills deal with the
same topic my first question why we have
two Bill same section the same section
of law the same section of
law yeah I'm I'm having a little bit of
a hard time understanding that so that's
probably my fault just no but no um
following up on that what um are
you at all open to the idea that some
sections of law should not be I I'm
presuming that there would be there
could easily be a gap of time when law
doesn't exist on that on a particular
topic um from the repeal date before it
gets reenacted M um suppose that would
be during the time that we have a um I
don't know a felony or a um or someone
that has to register on the sex offender
list or something along of a very
serious
nature can you foresee a time when when
there would be someone that would fall
between those gaps and and therefore um
not have a a piece of law affecting them
and be able to be um put on trial for
that action I I suppose that could
happen but at the same time if we have
three seven and 10 years respectively to
figure this out I think simple planning
could prevent that from occurring if we
know a law is going to expire in that
many years I I don't see why that would
be an issue is when we already know
that's coming up for instance the
committee could then just or not the
committee representative could then put
that same bill back into effect ahead of
time do you know I don't know I just
don't think that would be a major
problem but there could be perhaps some
provision added in here I'm not saying
this is this is you know written in
stone I just I think we need some
mechanism for a getting old bills off
the books that aren't effective and
don't represent the will of the people
currently but just haven't been repealed
because time is limited obviously in
this this
house
um again prerogative here um time is
limited you're right um but we're but
you're now um making more of an
infringement on time you're having us
rehash legislation that may have only
come up two or three years ago
automatically and I and I and I'm not
sure with Roman uh
4 why that can't be done now not with a
100 but but simply one why can't uh one
or two of of any constituents talk to us
about having a a bill repealed now
um because it wouldn't be an automatic
process you'd have to put the bill in
has to get scheduled and so forth where
this would just go right to the
committee no this is Roman four I'm
talking um yes in Roman 4 that would
have to be a 100 people that would sign
on yeah to to a petition somewhat um why
why a 100 why can't it just be done with
one now we can one person can speak to
you as a representative and ask to have
um a bill put in to repeal any section
of
law I just find this to be
more I think it would encourage more
citizen participation in a way and then
it would just automatically go to the
committee where they could review it I
just find it to be more streamlined I
don't know if that makes sense but in my
mind it makes it more streamlined so
they could just go to you and then now
you know okay there's at least 100
people in this state that just feel that
this bill is not necessary and then you
guys just take a quick vote it's five
minute hey up or down no okay boom it's
done and then you have to wait another
what every two years it can come up I
you know what I mean in my mind it seems
cleaner than having to schedule a
hearing this and that it could be done
on the committee's own time whenever
they want hey we have these petitions
let's look through them real quick get
it done um as far
as I forgot your first part of that
question fine thank you um rep actually
I'm gonna go with rep
Sheen morning good morning thank you for
taking my question um you were just
discussing about um like a good law that
may be um sunsetted MH and you know
there would be you know several years to
make sure that it gets reenacted so
nothing falls through the cracks who
would be tracking that because that
would be a lot of work tracking you know
a lot of laws who who would who would be
doing that
work I don't know in my mind it seemed
like it would just be automatic with the
bill once it's passed it would have a
date I I just I guess an Excel
spreadsheet I mean I don't know I I
don't think it would be that comp at to
do techn technologically but perhaps I'm
wrong just You' see okay these bills are
coming up for expiration maybe we can
make it so it turns yellow when they're
getting within six months and just kind
of go from
there yeah but who who would oversee
that process I suppose the
clerk thank you
thank thank you Mr chairman and and
following up on representative Shen's
questions um our house clerk has an
awful lot of work to do scheduling
everything all the time um I'm a little
surprised there's no fiscal note on this
because it's going to take more people
than our house clerk to handle this
volume we have what about a th000 bills
a year 900 to a th000 and um that means
someone's going to have to sit down and
keep going through bill after Bill after
Bill and you know they're all published
in those thick books that's going to how
is this a manageable process if I may
say I think we got to think about the
average person who lives in New
Hampshire not just the political class
but let's say a car mechanic and so
forth they have to know about all the
laws technically ignorance of the law is
no excuse so maybe we need to be cutting
down on the amount of laws we pass just
in general I I find it interesting that
we talk about the volume of laws but we
don't talk about the volume of laws that
the average person who's paying our
salaries have to Fig has to figure out
in order to navigate every day now we
can say well certain laws are specific
you know areas of the but still
technically we need to know of every law
that's passed and I just think there
needs to be more check on those laws and
I think giving them a lifespan like
people would kind of be a good thing rep
follow up thank you very much for your
answer um I'm looking at Roman numeral
number four down at the bottom of the
page yes and it says um upon receipt to
the SEC Secretary of State of 100
registered New Hampshire voters the
current law may be requested for repal
and then it goes on in terms of the
process of that sometimes it's not too
hard to get a 100 people to do something
but then you've got the whole rest of
the state are we going to put the this
whole process before the house to try to
figure out if something's to be repealed
because 100 people from One Community or
one District want it or how is this
going to
work
how would it work if 100 people say they
wanted a bill repealed well it would
come before the committee who has
jurisdiction over it or I don't know if
the proper word is for that but whoever
has the oversight of that and then they
would just have an up or down vote I
just think it should be on the record I
think it's important there's certain
laws that I don't believe people really
support anymore but there's not enough
political will to repeal them for
various reasons special interest groups
or so and I just think that this would
allow
now I I'm thinking of nonviolent
victimless crimes a lot of those kind of
bills that's really what this was aimed
for I I don't really care about Nuance
tax law state tax law kind of stuff that
doesn't really concern me but it's
things that people would end up on the
wrong side of the law for and losing
their Liberty on that's what I think is
important to reevaluate
frequently rep
sers thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representer for U bringing this forward
because one thing we do have is too many
bills we pass every year and 10 years
down the road we got three or 4,000
5,000 bills on the books so in addition
to what we already had so one of my
questions is is what happens to the
bills that get stuffed into
hb2 that's a good question
I I'll have to get back to on one
followup and and I realize you're
looking for guidance from us here as as
well it's and it's not a 100% Big Bill
but you're just bringing it forward for
us um are you expecting the repal
process or the the process that you got
here and and uh to go before committee
like us or i' go before the entire house
for repeal so you're referencing Roman
numeral 4 there 100 votes to I I was I
was thinking the committee would be a
better
environment because they have subject
matter knowledge of the topics at hand
or or supposedly do does if that makes
sense and they could just give an up and
down vote now if you should put some if
there should be some kind of mechanism
to challenge that on the floor I suppose
that could be done but yeah I didn't
really think that' be I'm trying to keep
this simple I got it down the one page
but it definitely could use a little bit
of love not going to lie I give you a
credit for for that uh R Pearson thank
you Mr
chair you
mentioned the lifespan of people but
this bill almost references the lifespan
of a goldfish yes okay when you're
talking about three three years seven
years 10 years
MH we currently process as on average
right about a thousand bills a
year we also
overturn about a third of our membership
each
election unless this passes and then it
would be about probably
90% in the next bium
but my question to you
is do you have a grasp of the volume of
work that would come forward to a
volunteer
legislature if this was
enacted 3 years from now with a house
that's virtually 5050 do you do you have
a sense of the volume of of the
workload let me address the first part
first the the reason Thomas Jefferson's
calculations of all laws and he included
the Constitution I don't think we really
should go that far but he figured it was
about 19 years a generation of men so
forth the reason I went with 3 S and 10
is they seem like good numbers but also
because nowadays it's much easier to see
if something is effective you can tell
if you pass a law if it reduces or
eliminates the problem for which it was
intended pretty quickly with technology
it doesn't take six months to send a
letter from New York to London so I
think the the time span can be sped up
drastically secondly the as far far as
the volume of
work I would again refer back to my
previous comments I I think if we're
requiring the average person lizen new
hampire to know all these laws then the
least we can do is look at these laws
every few years to figure out they're
actually doing what they're supposed to
do I I don't know I just have a
simplistic perhaps notion of laws and
the purpose of legislatures but I think
so this also came about real quickly I
was reading about I forget which
Scandinavian country it was but back in
around 1000 ad they had a title in the
government called the lawgiver and every
three years I'm sorry well every year he
would have to repeat verbatim from
memory a third of the law and anything
he didn't remember or speak was removed
from the books so the whole point being
is if you can't remember the laws you've
passed a maybe we have too many laws or
B maybe they're too complicated at the
you know for instance just real quick
federal law the IRS code 60 something
thousand pages and we're expecting the
average guy you know who's a
veterinarian or works on cars to figure
that out just so that's that's kind of
where I'm with that if that makes
sense sure last one okay
so I'm kind of uh the average guy I have
a full-time job I own a
house I have a
dog and I volunteer to come up here
weaving in and out of all of that
and I agree with representative wall
about the lack of a fiscal note here um
are you are you simultaneously
advocating then for this to become a
full-time legislature in order to handle
the workload that will come from this
proposal I'll just answer that with one
word never no I think the part-time
legislature is key to the New Hampshire
experience as it
were thank you um one thing I would ask
is uh you to complete a pink card oh
sorry about that yeah y you got it um
thank you other than that I think we're
good thank you very much thank you very
much I have no other pink cards on
this I do actually um our house clerk um
I didn't fill out a pink card but I will
can I speak real quick if you fill out a
pink card sure
um the chair recognizes our host clerk
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee um as you know Paul Smith
Clerk of the house uh as usual not
testifying in support or opposed to
legislation merely providing you some
information uh last week I briefly spoke
with the sponsor of this legislation um
expressing some uh concerns he asked me
how uh I thought he could make the bill
better um the only way truly I think uh
he can accomplish what he wants is that
any perspective
legislation going forward would have an
automatic repeal date that's the only
way I see this new mechanism working uh
because otherwise this idea uh is novel
um and and and I I say that uh in the in
the true sense of the word novel um I'm
not suggesting that putting in an
automatic repeal is a good idea I'm just
suggesting that that might be what the
sponsor is looking to do uh other than
that I do have some concerns I'd like to
share with you um specifically that the
language is vague confusing and not at
all correct in terms of structure in
Roman 4 for example it refers to the
appropriate statutory Committee in the
house with jurisdiction over the subject
matter of the bill it then goes on to
speak of the bill to be repealed um I
assume that this should be standing
committee of the house as a statutory
committee is defined in RSA 1449 as this
committee knows just about better than
anybody else in the planet after having
worked on this issue for the last three
years uh I to to representative
Pearson's Point structurally what
happens when the house is out of session
for those six months every year um
specifically during the summer and the
fall in the citizen initiated drive to
repeal a law uh by the by the way it
isn't a matter of repealing a bill
because once a bill is signed it is
law I want to make that distinction
clear it's not just a bill anymore it is
law uh here's another Point that's
concerning in order to repeal a law now
it has to go through the entire
legislative process meaning both bodies
and signed by the governor of New
Hampshire the language in this text
ignores the other branch of the general
court now granted I am a bit adversarial
to the other side of the wall as you all
know but we are still a by camera
legislature until you all pass cacr to
become a unical
legislature and frankly this language
ignores the deliberative nature of the
general court by having public hearings
or involving the Senate and admittedly
as a product of the house myself I can't
ignore that there's no mention of the
other body and their abilities as a
co-equal part of the legislature
therefore I am concerned about the
constitutionality of this
legislation I did speak with the
director of os last week and inquired
about the lack of fiscal note because uh
as the clerk and chief legislative
officer of the house I can tell you I
will need to hire somebody If This Were
to become law um to work exclusively on
this novel idea of tracking all house
passage of bills by
percentages uh possibly session only but
it would be a devoted staffer
nonetheless additionally as this would
be a new process involving not only the
legislative branch but the Secretary of
State as well I assume there may be
additional incom is felt by that office
in order to fulfill the novel mission of
this
legislation additionally as this
committee well knows um having worked
extensively on rsa1
1449 there have been
workarounds since that legislation was
passed our new favorite word is
notwithstanding and legislation is
frequently drafted now that says
notwithstanding RSA 1449 a commission
consisting of 900 persons shall be
formed doing whatever and I am concerned
that you know even if this were to pass
the the notwithstanding loophole would
would essentially become part of any
piece of legislation moving forward and
that would be perfectly
allowable
lastly we don't simply nullify in the
legislature my friends we do not simply
nullify this this language in section 4
is a form of direct democracy that was
not envisioned by the framers of the New
Hampshire Constitution otherwise it
would be explicitly enumerated so given
those points uh I I felt it necessary to
um share with you those concerns
regarding this piece of
legislation thank you Mr clar uh any
questions seeing none thank you very
much I have one last pink card on this
uh this bill um the chair recognizes uh
representative patent
who indicates she's not supporting or
opposing but apparently wishing to
amend welcome to legislative
Administration thank you um so of course
I'm here to testify on the next bill
that's up so I just wanted to speak
literally one minute on this only
because I understand where the sponsor
was coming from
and I believe
especially being in new rep
um let's just talk about the volume of
bills 900 a th000 or what's going what
what runs through and there's no checks
and balances that's really the problem
there's there's no one that's telling
you and they're all paid in OSS hey this
bill is really unconstitutional this
shouldn't be filed and that would
decrease the level of bills that are
coming in and I don't know if it would
be ger to amend it like that but there
needs to be like checks and balances
that are in there and instead of us of
course and I understand where he's
coming from we're passing all of these
laws right and a lot of them that are on
the books um there's tons of conf
conflicts in statute I know we're
handling it um I know HHS is handling
some of those conflicts they're being
handled in committees all the time we
handled it three times last time where
we're basically passing something to
make it make sense because it says one
thing over here and says another thing
over there I mean I just I think going
through all of our laws on the books and
really showing where they where they are
you know unconstitutional in repealing
them is is totally a pathway I think we
should be focused on that as the
legislature you know it's kind of like a
dual thing I have no idea how if that
could be amended here but in a sense
that's where I I kind of hear where he's
coming from because we get very very
busy pushing things through and you know
there's a lot of laws that are on the
books that if they don't have any
enforcement mechanism and no teeth
they're not worth the paper that they're
written on so um making the book bigger
doesn't help so I just wanted to give my
two cents on that thank you very much um
I don't speaking out of turn here and
and for the whole committee I don't
think we are um adversarial to the to
the idea and I do personally appreciate
any kind of new idea that comes along
that can address the volume I look at it
as just the opposite I think this
increases the the volume exponentially
um I think we'll be looking over bills
that um that we just we just looked at
but you know I I too can be wrong um I I
think I don't want to selch new ideas
coming forward though um and I do think
that is uh to be applauded right thank
thank you for your
time having no other pink cards I think
I'm ready to close the hearing
on I lost it uh House Bill
1495 it'll be a minute here to reset and
then we'll start in on House Bill 1666
FN
wa
the time being
940 um we'll open the hearing on House
Bill 1666 FN relative to income
reporting requirements for
lobbyists uh chair recognizes the prime
sponsor rep
Penza um who has obviously in support of
the bill and says she needs three
minutes to discuss welcome
back
thank you Mr chair uh I come to you
today um this was probably um one of the
first ideas I had to put in a bill most
of the other ideas came from
constituents and just from the
experience of of being here um you know
kind of as a just a regular Regular Joe
activist in coming to testify committees
and now being a part of the legislature
um I've just noticed some some real
issues and I sent this this bill idea
out uh to the entire house and I got a
huge amount of response um this is a
this is a nonpartisan I heard from just
as many uh Democrats as I did from
Republicans that are um interested in
this and they had to be turned away
because not everybody of course can be
signed on as a co-sponsor
um requiring lobbyists to report their
income it's really crucial for
transparency and accountability in the
political process when lobbyists
disclose their income it helps identify
of course potential conflicts of
interest between their financial
interests and the policies specifically
that they advocate for so this
transparency allows the public and
policy makers to understand the
financial relationships between
lobbyists and their entities and the
industries of course that they represent
full disclosure of income expenditures
by lobbyists of course helps prevent
corruption undue influence unethical
practices in government decision making
it allows for a clear understanding of
who is attempting to influence policy
makers and to what extent fostering a
more transparent and Equitable
Democratic constitutional republic
process additionally it enables
regulatory bodies to monitor compliance
with lobbying laws and regulations and
of course it ensures that lobbying
activities adhere to the same ethical
standards that we all do have to um in
the legislature or as um holding
political
office so I think one of the biggest
concerns about with politicians or
associations corporations paying
lobbyists isn't inherently about the act
itself because uh especially for uh
seasoned legislators that are here um
it's a legitimate way for various
interests to communicate their
viewpoints to law makers they have uh
they they get paid a lot we we get paid
um $100 so uh they get paid a lot and
they have research teams and things like
that which is great so having those
having that information is wonderful but
there's potential issues that arise when
that relationship pretty much between
these entities politicians lobbyists
corporations all of that kind of stuff
involves con conflict of interest lack
of transparency and undo influence so
I believe that this bill um Can can help
uh write a ship that I think is steering
in the wrong direction um there has been
there's been so much that uh I will send
you my testimony um there has been a lot
of stuff that's been printed on this for
several years and just in 2019 there was
a a wonderful article that was on nhpr
that says you know as LOB being in New
Hampshire grows more complex it's nearly
impossible to follow the money in New
Hampshire that's a
problem so I asked a question I'm in the
straford county um along with
representative wall so you we're you
know our delegation smaller than of
course you know Rockingham and and
Hillsboro but and just to kind of
understand the level of you know
lobbying efforts or people that are
hired to do government relation and
things like that so there's a there's a
you know it's a County Association that
has all of the counties that are part of
it and I just didn't understand there
how the County Association which is all
elected officials are who's paying into
that Association than to pay a lobbyist
when that lobbyist is here working
against
legislation that is representative maybe
of a republican principal so there's so
much conflicts of interest and when I
asked those questions to um one of the
lobbying groups here uh in New Hampshire
I got back like where this you know New
Hampshire Association of counties for
example is paying tens of thousands of
dollars that's our money to then be used
against potential legislation that I
could file or others can file it just
seems like a a a a a circle that needs
to be um cut off and and I can give lots
of other examples that I've seen um
through uh agencies um that are really
concerning um where you know an agency
says that they're they don't have any
stake in the game and then they come and
they send letters and testimony and then
you have you automatically see that the
same talking points that are coming from
the lobbying group is what the agency is
saying and um um and lots and lots of
meetings that are happening in these
agencies that are working against the
legislature where in a sense we're
supposed to be you know we're supposed
to be kind of the the driving factor
with different agencies whether it be
you know Dees um there's just a you know
HHS there's a lot of that stuff that's
going on so that's why I filed this bill
um I've got overwhelming support I have
one amendment that I'm going to make and
the only reason why it wasn't put in was
because you know um this came to me when
OLS was backed up I had a change they
couldn't put it in based upon the
deadline it is on uh line nine uh on
page two and it says um it says the
amount dates received and source of all
income earned by the lobbyist in the
prior calendar year in excess of
$5,000 and then we wipe out for lobbying
activity um that line gets wiped out and
then whether paid directly by the client
the employer or or other third party
that is the change I'm going to take out
those three words so there'll be
Amendment coming in for that and then I
can send you a whole bunch of resources
about this as well
so any
questions I don't know I will ask
um rep Pearson you have a question I do
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
presenting this to us this
morning I'm I'm trying to grasp
a practical
reality of this activity
so here's my here's my question to you
the
NRA have
as an organization lobbyists in New
Hampshire okay would that
lobbyist who is works for the NRA have
to
file a massive massive report showing
all of the income the sources and the
work that the NRA does nationally
because they're not it's not an
outsourced lobbying firm they don't pay
a firm that's like across the street
that we have the lobbying firms that
that exist in conquered they send their
person directly from the
organization so how is that logistically
going to work when you have a National
Organization coming to Lobby before this
body so this really speaks to all of the
processes that have been in place for a
long time so for example if I'm going to
register for a lobbyist I've got to have
an orange badge I'm kind of walking
around all the Halls here this is really
what that applies to if someone is
coming in to speak let's say they're a
guest speaker and they're working for a
national lobbying group they are not
coming here to New Hampshire they're not
working in New Hampshire they don't
they're not filing and having to give
that kind of information to be
registered here in the state they don't
have to have an orange badge to come
testify that's not happening as
frequently as what I'm talking about
this bill speaks specifically to the
folks in New Hampshire is what I'm
talking about
here I'm sensing there will be a
followup
only because that's not how it works the
NRA if they bring a lobbyist to New
Hampshire to testify they have to
register that's not optional so they
they they're not coming up here to speak
as a private citizen I'm just using it
as an example because they because
they're a large National
Organization they are not exempt from
our very specific lobbying rules that
exist in this building so I'm just
trying to get the Practical reality of
how
they will comply with this if it
passes So based upon my
knowledge I don't so for example in a
this was before I was a State Rep there
was um a doctor that was part of um an
association in a sense that came here to
testify they were part they were coming
they said that they were coming on
behalf of themselves as a doctor not as
that Association which is a lobbying
group as well they didn't have to
register they came in they flew in from
another state to testify so I understand
where you're coming from but those are
one-off situations they are not if they
if they are here testifying on a regular
basis they're going to have to have the
orange badge that's not
happening what in what you're talking
about you're talking about like one-off
situations anybody that is here on a
regular basis that registers with the
state to be able to testify on a regular
basis they're I mean they're
you guys know you're in the Committees
they're here all the time I'm how many
are here right now so um there we see
the same faces over and over that's what
I'm talking about I I I think I can
clarify a little bit there's a
miscommunication going on there are
organizations that um are National
organizations that have lobbyists here
um that are registered lobbyists they do
qualify under the lobbying
category the concern I think the
representative has is when they belong
to that that National
Organization they would have to under
this the language of
this would they not have to list all of
their
lobbying
Nationwide for the entire
organization that's that was I think the
question
it's so they are listing under three the
amount dates received and source of all
income earned by the lobbyist in Prior
calendar year in excess of $5,000
whether paid directly by the client the
employer or third party I'm here I'm
coming to testify I work for the NRA I
get paid
$70,000 I'm going to report where that
income is coming from who my clients are
that's it not I'm not we're not having
the NRA disclose every entity that's
paying them no this is specific to the
employee
the person that's it's just exactly
think of it like us what we have to
report every single one of us here has
to do disclosures and report that kind
of income that is what I'm asking we're
we're asking for the same playing field
that the politicians have to do for the
people here that are following
legislation a lot more closely than most
of us that are in that
400 thank
you other questions
comments seeing none thank you for your
testimony the next pin card I have is
for representative gearhard um who says
he supports the bill and needs two
minutes actually
less representative Gard Northfield
Franklin so I'm actually a co-sponsor on
this bill and I was just going to speak
to
the financial um fiscal note so the
Secretary of State believes that they'll
need to hire a new employee to monitor
the filings at $35,000 a year I would
somebody said no oh so my only
suggestion would be that this fee burden
be taken on by the lobbyists some way
some shape some form some kind of fee
just to offset it from the actual
general public just a minor note that's
all I only need a minute something like
how New York city has the taxi
medallions so we need little lobbyist
medallions all right so that's all I
want to say thank you thank you uh
further
question would
you if you're willing to take it
sure just so I understand
you you are going to requ require
someone pay a permit to
speak in front of a committee in a
public hearing it's a fee to offset the
cost of monitoring their
compliance okay I'm just so the answer
you're giving me is yes M
okay thank
you we have a late entrance
um you were also looking for written t
right on this um rep tenza you mentioned
that you had um testimony testimony but
also a written amendment is there an
amendment
coming thank
you sorry about that um no you're you're
do I have a um a pink card for
you
there um we have before us Olivia Zen um
and and supports the bill with edits uh
and is asking for 2 minutes representing
open democracy um good morning members
of the committee my name is Olivia zinc
I'm a voter in Franklin and I represent
an organization called open democracy
who believes in transparency and I think
what this bill is trying to get to is
additional transparency I do uh want to
say that on line five the name address
and phone number of the lobbyist is
something we already do um so probably
not additional need to the stat stute on
line nine for prior calendar year
currently uh lobbyists file April um
24th for the period of activity January
February and March um they're filed
quarterly they file quarterly reports so
I do think line nine needs to sort of be
consistent with the quarterly reports
unless we want to change these reports
to annual which I don't think is
probably needed quarterly is probably
acceptable y quarterly is you can keep
that on line
20 I think that it would be important
for the Secretary of State and the
Attorney General to look at who enforces
these uh laws um I did write to know the
Attorney General to see how many
enforcements they've done on lobbying
reports and I got a big fat zero uh
they've never enforced this law um so I
think that it's more important that the
law get enforced whether it's the
attorney general or the Secretary of
State or who does that I do like this
notion um that online um
28 whereas if a lobbyist is 10 days late
filing the report the S the Secretary of
State sends an email notifying them to
to complete their report I do want to
tell this committee that um on September
21st 2021 there was a note from the
attorney general to Bill Gardner on how
to file the laws because they're
confusing and lobbyists fill out these
things inconsistently I do recommend the
committee read this attorney general's
memo
um because right now every lobbyist
fills out reports differently and I
think um it's important for us to
realize how many register lobbyists pay
$50 annually to register um 10 years ago
in 2014 we had 249 registered lobbyists
um I looked at I tried to pull up
today's numbers but there wasn't a
spreadsheet yet be I think it's just
because people are still filing
registrations for the year so it would
be interesting
um but in um 2008 here's the list of
registered lobbyists it's 89 pages long
with 10 to 11 P names per lobbyist so we
have had a huge growth in that um I do
also want to point out open Secrets
ranked all 50 states with a score of 20
on state lobbying disclosure and New
Hampshire gets a 10.25 so we're getting
half of what we should be for disclosure
um timel uh but userfriendly so so
people can find this information we get
a0 75 our system is not userfriendly
it's done on paper quarterly there is no
way to email your lobbyist report to the
Secretary of State you can only fax it
or hand deliver it or mail it so maybe
thinking about it's a it's a fillable
PDF why not let them fill it send it
into the secretary of state that way the
Secretary of State doesn't have to scan
all of these reports then when you try
to find it on the Secretary of State
website good luck cuz it's really
difficult to find them but I did bring
examples of multiple different lobbyists
who fill out these reports in wildly
different ways um so right now there's
just very inconsistency of how lobbying
reports are filled out and maybe we
could look at simplifying the form and
making the form clear because the the
form says by all your clients and some
people do the totals but it should be of
that client that you're filing the
report for um which is you know you
could you could change the way the form
is read and and I think you might get
more compliance I'm happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions I have one um I had uh circled
the part um online three for a single
clear concise and accurate Financial
disclosure statement we would all like
to think that our financial statements
are clear concise and accurate um but it
would seem to me that if there was a
single
form it would um make it easier for
anyone that has to try to um weed
through any of these financial
statements in order to get the correct
information is that clear uh well
currently you have to fill out your
cover page one let me just say there's
uh multiple pieces of paper that a
lobbyist has to fill out they have to
fill out this piece of paper with their
the name of their lobbyist the name of
their partnership firm or Corporation um
and the period of the which they're
filing it then they have to do an
addendum a and the addendum a is several
pages long which lists the amount that's
paid in that period um and the expenses
so the fees received and the expenses
you then have to do an amendment B and
the amendment B is if I bought you a cup
of coffee I'd have to write that I
bought a Lobby uh somebody a cup of
coffee or whatever you know I think that
there is a limit so maybe a cup of
coffee doesn't qualify I think it has to
be over $5 but sometimes coffee a Tesla
can be $5 actually there we can't gift
Lobby lobbyists can't gift you anything
more than $25 so you know if I'm GNA buy
you a few beers I have to buy bed light
a couple of them um because I can't give
you more than 25 um then they have to
file addendum C which is any political
contributions that lobbying firms made
the addendum C's are frankly the
messiest part of this process because
many lobbyists make political
contributions but the addendum C's don't
reconcile with our campaign Finance
reports I've tried and I can't get
addendum C's and then there's another
piece of paper that the lobbyist has to
file so you've got your addendum a your
addendum B and then you have to file
this signature form so the amount of
pieces of paper each period is pretty
repetitive and could be simplified I
believe um and I think there was a
committee that looked at this a couple
of years ago um but I also think with
our online
technology um filing these by paper
might not be what we want to do um we
might be able to make them fillable PDFs
and be able to submit them but currently
the law says they have to be printed and
hand delivered or faxed um or
mailed great thank you I think that did
answer exactly what I was trying to get
to um seeing no other thank you very
much for your testimony um I have no
other pink tards
correct I think we're all set uh thank
you I'm going to close the
perfect thank you very
much before I
close no I I am going to close uh the
hearing on uh House Bill
FN be a couple minutes here and we'll
reset and pull up house resolution
for
okay uh few minutes late I apologize for
that uh we'll open the hearing on um HR
25 couple of quick statements on this um
we do have a hard stop at noon time um
and then I'll have a couple of um
informational notices for the committee
um at that point we're going to
rearrange some of the schedule um
beginning just at 12:00 or the afternoon
session um I would ask as we call you to
the witness table that uh you state your
name and the organization or whom you
are
representing
um and whether you are for or against
and most of that is for the um recording
that we're doing uh
simultaneously um I'm going to I don't
want to um limit the time speaking never
like that personally um
but it looks to me like everyone's
asking for a reasonable amount of time
and it would seem that we can fit that
into the be prior to the hard deadline
um please if you can concentrate on um
giving us new information if you agree
with a prior speaker simply say I agree
with the prior speaker um rather than
try to uh tell us the same information
over and over again
um that would be helpful um I do want to
to keep the conversation
to the resolution itself not to any of
the underlying U
issues
and beyond that are there any other
instructions that we have written
testimony uh I've been reminded by the
clerk written testimony is always good
um two minutes is sometimes hard and
some people people uh like to prefer or
like to give us a written testimony that
does go in the file and I will uh
personally promise that I do read all of
the written
testimony um other than that I think
we're good to go um the chair will
recognize the prime
sponsor um if I can find the card there
it is uh rep Panic is that correct did I
pronounce that correctly correct
um you asked for three minutes welcome
to the legislative
Administration thank you for your
testimony red light there you go thank
you chairman and honorable members of
the committee my name is representative
Sandra panck I'm from palum New
Hampshire at Hillsboro District
1 um I want to start off by
reading something off my cell phone
um Mason's manual chapter 2 Section
7 paragraph one says that the
Constitutions stand on a higher plane
than statute and as a rule are
mandatory there are statutes re
regarding election process which
conflict with the house with the New
Hampshire
Constitution this resolution nullifies
any conflicting statutes by resolving to
return to strict
observance if the original Law of the
original Law New York pistol and rifle
versus Bruin shows that the original Law
is the highest standard in America and I
have a
little additional blur I want to read we
are a constitutional
republic and so we are answering then
Franklin's
challenge to Endeavor to keep it
remember we all took an oath to the New
Hampshire Constitution as well as the
United States Constitution the day we
were sworn into
office we must all remember that our
rights are not just on paper but lived
and breath breathed every single day
oats bind the party to observe a certain
course of conduct or to fulfill certain
d duties in the future or to demean
himself thereafter in a stated manner
with reference to specified objects or
obligations this is what legislators are
committed to do when we take our
roots with regards to the towns who
voted to use machines they are all
creatures of the legislation legislator
and cannot override the law for example
a town no more vote to have machines
count in their town can then they can
vote to ban gun ownership in their town
if random towns could vote to override
the
Constitution that would be called an
arbitrary power the law says that
arbitrary power exists nowhere in a
republic not even in the largest
majority are we being viewed as
troublemakers because we want handcom
found in the pro-abortion crowd views us
as troublemakers for wanting to stop the
murder of babies and yet we press on
because it is right it is simply the law
to hand count each town will suddenly
get very motivated to be efficient with
counting once they see their votes won't
count if they don't do it by hand don't
forget if this passes even the Democrats
will rally in the with the Republicans
to make sure they get counted on time
because they want their votes to count
just as much as we do but we have some
good suggestions too that we can make
but the success of
hr25 resolution should be tied to the
mere truth of defending the law not
escaping being seen as
troublemakers cost analysis may be a
helpful tool however there are some
legis lators who do not care how much
the machines cost in terms of not having
them at all to some the ability to cheat
and not have to stay late counting far
outweighs any cost and though and for
those who know we don't care how
inexpensive they can be we want them
gone this is the law and it's written in
our
constitution the reason 640 election
laws suits failed is they all alleged
fraud which cannot be proven without
eyewitnesses instead to claim
maladministration not following the
rules would have gotten us all somewhere
so now is our chance we keep it simple
the rules must be followed or the result
is impossible to know and
certify maxim of law where the law
prescribes a form the non observance of
it is fatal to the proceeding if you
have not heard about this resolution
it's important to understand what it
means with regard to PR preservation of
your position if your position is
important to you without this resolution
you stand to lose your lead in the house
by
2024 and possibly never regain it this
is a
nonpartisan resolution which helps
Preserve our positions I will not be
taking any questions and I will be
handing this over to our constitutional
experts to answer your questions thank
you for your
time thank you for your testimony can I
ask one question do you have written
testimony that you
are that would be great thank you very
much sorry for the
question um I'm going to break a little
bit with uh with our nor normal pattern
here um but only in the interest of time
um our house clerk um has duties that he
needs to be somewhere else so I'd like
to call our house clerk Paul Smith to
the
St
welcome honorable clerk thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee again
Paul Smith Clerk of the house um thank
the I'd like to thank the member for uh
quoting my favorite book Mason's manual
legislative procedure um I actually have
a couple of other sections of Mason's
manual legislative procedure that are
important for this discussion today uh
again not here opposed to or in support
of this legislation uh merely to provide
a few uh conceptual points number one
ladies and gentlemen this is a house
resolution it has no eff of law it is
very important to understand this would
State a position of the House of
Representatives and the house of
represent resentatives only it does not
speak for the general court therefore
sections um contained within
specifically in the resolving Clauses uh
where it says resolve by the House of
Representatives that the general court
blank intends to do Etc uh again this
resolution does not speak for the
general court and therefore does not
contain any fact of law included in it
uh
additionally
um looking forward to to additional
resolving
Clauses where it says specifically on
page three beginning in Roman 5 intends
to require equivalent rigor of
witnessing standards submitted to the
people's demand for equal voting rights
to come benefit from elections and no
unequal classes of unqualified voters
and and specifically requires the
Secretary of State to follow actions
later we can't do that ladies and
gentlemen that the only only way that
can be done is by amending law and
addressing that in statute or
specifically through Constitutional
Amendment concurrent
resolutions the section of Mason's
manual I I found it uh prudent to
discuss with you as well as many of you
know this is a matter of adjudication
between uh private parties and the state
of New Hampshire and is currently before
the New Hampshire Supreme Court uh
arguments were delivered late last fall
and the Supreme Court is uh deciding
what they're doing at this moment in
time if this was a piece of legislation
where it would effective effectively uh
have something to do with law there's no
issue with that but because this is a
resolution specifically where it talks
about our positions
uh I would remind you um in section 112
of Mason Mason's Manual of legislative
procedure any matter awaiting
adjudication before a Judicial tribunal
shall not be debated or discussed in a
legislative body I want to repeat that
again a matter awaiting adjudication
before a Judicial tribunal shall not be
debated or discussed in a legislative
body again this is different than a bill
this is a position statement in the form
of a resolution and therefore I I do
think that you you have some concerns
that you need to address uh in how this
resolution is drafted uh because of of
that very
language and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr cler other
questions yes representative Pearson
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr clerk
for coming before us your uh knowledge
and expertise on Mason is
unquestioned
let's run this through the process it
passes the
house then what happens to it if it
passes the house thank you for the
question representative as you know a
house resolution simply is a position of
the house nothing happens with this bill
excuse me this resolution because um
there is no instruction for the clerk to
follow uh it merely States your
intention however the intentions that it
states has requirements in it specific
to requiring the Secretary of State to
accomplish uh certain means that go
beyond the authority of this one uh body
of the by camera legislature uh to
enact follow
up anyone
else I have a quick question yes sir um
the section of Masons that you just
stated um do we have a problem with the
hearing itself um or no sir I I would
suggest not because it is a duly filed
piece of legislation uh by a member of
the of the of the of the house uh
therefore is certainly within your
perview uh to take up that piece of
legislation I would just suggest that as
the matter is pending before The Supreme
Court of this state um that perhaps a
decision you might want to wait for a
decision to come before uh reconciling
that through executive session later
this year or um potentially study the
issue
further okay um follow up if I if if the
the um resolution comes through the
executive SE exec our executive session
here and goes to the floor um does the
debate that takes place on the floor
have issues with
Masons I I think that there are some
concerns about what you can talk about
within the within the framework of
what's contained in the lawsuit
especially as uh we are a party to that
lawsuit thank you any you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr
chairman now we'll revert back to um
protocol um which is to to bring up um
Representatives first um I have
representative gearhard uh who is asked
to speak for two minutes and support the
bill welcome again representative
Gearhart it's your lucky day yes thank
you I just want to make clarification so
representative Gard Northfield Franklin
for uh thank you um for the record can
you um state name town and and um who
you represent and you're um supporting
or or opposing the bill thanks yes Jason
Gard Northville Franklin and I am
support of this bill I'm actually a
co-sponsor this bill I misspoke I am not
a co-sponsor on 1666 we just heard I
don't know how that okay we let you get
through that one though yeah I notice
appreciate it this as far as I'm
concerned this bill simply
reasserts things that we already hold to
be true if you make take an oath you
should follow it the Constitution should
be
sacren because that's the rule book
we're following and I just want to say
real quickly as far as the electronic
counting machines go and and all of that
it's clearly unconstitutional
and I I feel that more and more people
are losing faith in the system of voting
and I think that is part of what this is
trying to rectify because if people lose
faith in voting then we're really headed
down a bad road because as JFK said
those who make peaceful Revolution
impossible make violent revolution
inevitable and I I do hold that to be
true and I think history has proven that
to be true so I
simply think we should go back to basics
start following the Constitution and and
every vote counts especially when it's
done by hand and not just by some
computer we're hoping is uh doing the
right thing so that's all I wanted to
say thank you thank you uh do you take
questions if we have any of course are
there any questions for rep
gear seeing none you're off the hook
than thank
you uh next pink card I have um is for
uh rep uh Penza as
well
sure um but I'll I'll determine the
order here
thanks I have um Wayne
seya
senior asking for five to 10 minutes um
if that could be less than that it would
be terrific um we will I see you have
testimony we would be be happy to take
as fast as I can thank you for your help
okay welcome to legislative
Administration this is my first time I'm
a retired uh
CEO uh out of nashal New Hampshire I've
been there for 30 years uh and I uh I'm
here because um uh because of the term
legislative intent I have can I
interrupt for a second can you introduce
yourself and and who you represent and
your support or or opposition to the
Bill thank you you recognize I haven't
been here before uh my name is Wayne
seya um I support the
bill I am uh a former CEO uh living in
nashv for the past 30 years uh about
working out of DC uh where my office was
um so I did a lot of fly and um I I I
support the bill individually for my on
have of myself because of the tens of
thousands of dollars I support
candidates uh in the state um within the
past 30 years uh which is probably now
over a couple hundred thousand dollars
and um one of the uh I've um uh been an
electronic design engineer um uh I've um
I have I hold two US patents with regard
to electronic designs and frequency and
I also um have written a book with
regard to the safety of uh buildings and
Facilities where I've taken care of a
number of those facilities uh on Capitol
Hill uh in Boston uh with the John
Hancock Tower and and so on so I won't
belabor that with you if you want my
um uh resume I'm happy to give you my
all 15 pages of
it um okay um a reason I support the
bills because of the term legislative
intent that I've been hearing and um I
participate ated in a um in a recount
election in Nashua just a couple of
weeks ago and uh there was a number uh
an extremely large number of absentee
ballots that were used in that election
none of which uh the the board of
alderman uh would want to take a look at
with regard to the affidavit and we're
not talking about examining the
signature we're talking about the
legitimacy of the affidavit itself
they refuse to hear it um but most
importantly uh I found uh quite bizarre
is that the this legislature passed
bills that stipulates that the um school
districts shall run the elections and
it's plain right inside the the laws but
yet all over the state because of the
term legislative
intent um Board of Alderman and the city
council are running the elections
against what the statutes call for
statute to me was pretty clear um it's
in front of a couple of judges right now
who just don't really want to rule on it
because you've been doing it for so long
so because of the term legislative
intent now when I see a piece of
legislation that says the school
district shall run the elections in this
way and then that law is pushed aside
because of legislative intent and
because of the way we've done things all
along and they're having the school the
um cities and towns run the elections to
me that's a problem with regard to
education with regard to elections um
you've opened up a Pandora box with
regard to not following what I believe
the Constitutional intent is because now
they brought in electronic design into
this issue and I've had um hard surgery
on a couple of occasions so there are
certain frequencies I can't go up to and
there are fre frequencies that people
who are pacemakers can't go near and and
when you're talking about these
particular people um they decide not to
vote because they've been told by their
doctors don't wear a Walkman too close
to your your pacemaker don't go too
close to election machines because of
the frequency of the timing mechanism
that's used in those machines and and so
therefore the the way that votes used to
be counted um was just the way that it's
stipulates within the Constitution all
of a sudden you've introduced electronic
systems and the only way to protect from
those systems the legislature repealed
it a few years ago and made this called
an oosha State um and now that we're in
oosha state with regard you see anytime
you have an electronic device it has to
be what's called Safety certified
meaning it falls under underwriter
Laboratories or the other 21 safety
certification companies that do that the
machines that have been used in this
state for the past 15 years they lost
their certification eight years ago
which means osia is not allowed now to
use that so when that was brought into
court the court says well the
legislative intent says that it's
probably okay nobody's ever brought it
into federal court because if they did
the federal court would say oh you're in
violation of oosha and and so when you
try to bring it into the state court the
state court says that's a federal issue
and all the state has to do is just
follow the Constitution and uh follow
the Constitutional intent of what it
says um uh go for the safety of the
people such as myself I mean I haven't
now donated to a republican cause in two
years because of the term legislative
intent so I think the legislature uh
maybe starting from this committee and
I'm not saying this uh to to to belittle
anybody but you guys need to get your
act together um and start looking at
who's voting and who's not voting
because of electronic devices that have
been incorporated into the state that
have now caused a potential Hazard
reason why o is there is not because of
the hazard itself it's because of the
potential Hazard and that's what o is
there for either that or go down to the
some Electronics committee or some tell
them to reestablish that bill that they
repealed that way there the state canot
take a look at the machines but I I'm
saying this because I'm a professional
witness for seven different attorneys in
New Hampshire and I've told them all
this and they said well Wayne this is
too political can you just write to this
issue or that issue because there's
probably a problem with the legislative
intent of what you're saying and we
don't want to scare the the voters of
the city of the city or the state and
I'm saying well I'm not trying to scare
anybody I'm just you know what did
Truman once say I'm not trying to give
anybody hell I'm just giving you the
facts and it sounds like hell
so um that's all I have and if I'm happy
to answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
um are there any
questions seeing none thank you again
it's my pleasure first time you can't
use that anymore you now that you're
done you're a
veteran
um is that written testimony at my Clark
just reminds me is that written
testimony that you have for us it's not
it showed me how to get
here but to submit it you it obviously
works then right yeah thank
you
um you now no okay hold on um next I the
uh chair will recognize David Kylie
um ask for three minutes in support of
the bill
hand
out welcome to legislative
Administration thank you guys want these
yes
yeah
okay if you could introduce yourself and
who you represent and
my name is David Kylie I represent
myself in support of
hr25 as one of the people in part one
article one exercising my right to give
notice in instruction and demand of
exact observance to the fundamental
principles of our Constitution under
part one article 8 32 and
38 um I'm going to get started I'm not
sure everyone has it in hand yet but
really one it's it's only 10 slides so
it shouldn't take too long I wanted to
go over the no really go over the uh the
affidavit absentee issue which is
essentially Germain to much of the U
much of the the resolution uh the first
slide is is affidavit and I'm I'm just
providing the definition of affidavit as
it exists in Black's Law which which is
clear that it's it's something that it
needs to be confirmed by oath sworn to
or or firmed uh before an officer with
authority to administer an oath uh or
taken before an author an an officer
having authority to administer such oath
um in
1942 um you know when the amendment was
passed for absentee voting um the
legislature itself also had uh similar
definitions for what an oath was and
they had safeguards in place requiring
that um an affidavit with an absentee
ballot be sworn and so there was no
question about what an affidavit was
okay so if anyone's not clear that was
1942 and there were several safeguards
that were put into place by the
legislation at the time of the amendment
and at the time of the amendment is a
really important concept for everyone to
understand what did they mean when they
passed it we had statute that actually
tells us what they meant um and those
safeguards were really designed to make
sure that you know the the art part one
article 11 which calls for an equal
rights to voting that we didn't have
different class of Voters that were
similarly situated so we don't want to
have a polling place at a you know at a
at a community center where everyone has
to go in and every movement is
controlled from the point that they're
in line to you know getting an ID to a
blank ballot to the to the to the to the
Privacy Booth all the way through the um
you know to when they insert it into a
machine or put it into a Ballot Box okay
all those movements are controlled by
Statute as opposed to the absente
process which once somebody has a blank
ballot they can do anything they want
with it they can traffic it they can
they can be electioneered um they can
you know pretty much have somebody else
sign it for them because no one's
checking so this there's quite a big
distinction in the way people are
treated at that 1942 they recognized
safeguards you know needed to be very
similar and we just don't have that
anymore 1979 it was thrown
out so I'm going to move on to um I
think I just really said why affidavits
are required so further down in the in
the presentation I've provided for uh an
RSA that we currently have on the books
um
65717 and this is really where it we are
you know telling um the voter uh who has
an AB absentee ballot uh what they have
to do they have to execute the affidavit
right and in
6593 we have a definition know statutes
have def definitions we we have an 6
5930 says that uh an affidavit must be
sworn again going back to just like
black law and what existed back in 1942
still currently on the books we have to
execute an affidavit and we Define that
it's got to be done you know in front of
somebody who is qualified to administer
an oath so what happened
1979 we passed the that's this one right
here it's gray okay
1979 it appears that the legislature
decided to cut off the part where the
affidavit execution piece is
required and that's why we have this
house resolution okay how can we
possibly swear to something in front of
someone who needs who's qualified to
administer an oath if it's not on the
envelope so believe it or not I'm almost
done um the the
6577 which is the affidavit envelope is
not an affidavit it's an affidavit
velope legislature cannot just change a
a label of something and call it an
affidavit because they want to okay it's
a self-certification it's
meaningless okay um I'm going to leave
this slide because I think somebody else
is going to speak speak to whether or
not legislature can change the intent of
the Constitution so we can skip
that okay and I'm going to briefly
discuss another element of absentee
ballot uh the absentee ballot which is
you know whether or not we the legisl
can simply add religious employment care
of children in the infirmed or whether
as reasons for um allowing somebody to
have an absentee ballot you know we are
very explicit in article 11 part one
article 11 it's absent from the city or
town which they are
inhabitants there's no it's clearly a
geographical issue where you live if
you're not there you can have an
absentee ballot or physical disability
that is defined back in 1942 as a doctor
a physician they have to certify that
you're actually physically disabled when
we add things you know that's violating
a maximum of law the inclusion of one is
is to the exclusion of another the
certain designation of one person is an
absolute exclusion of all others yet the
legislature did
it finally my final remarks are and I
think it was briefly mentioned and I
agree with the gentleman that spoke
before me where he said that you know
these these uh moderators had uh um they
had un um they had uncertified absentee
ballot envelopes and you know the the
moderator is only allowed to remove the
ballot from the envelope if he can show
that it's been certified none of these
have been certified I don't know how
many were Nash but I'm thinking
Statewide and I'm thinking about prior
elections where the the rates of
absentee balloting went way up they
skyrocketed to like
32% how many of these have been
certified and included in the the ballot
stream think about that so just in
closing I just I would appreciate that
this committee if they're going to take
up any rebuttal to anything that I put
here which has been submitted already to
the record uh through the website um
that you you know that you uh share uh
any dialogue and especially if if you
could do it in written format I'd
appreciate it because I think that no
one has been able to rebut any of this
information to this
point and thank the Lord for having me
here thank you appreciate it um are you
open to taking questions if there are I
am y
sure do we have questions uh we have one
um representative
mcarter thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
coming here today sir to address this
house resolution I understand there's a
lot of uh conflicting opinion on it but
I can clearly see yours um a question
for you was something you you you uh
made me think about with regards to this
presentation it's obviously you put some
time into uh creating a PowerPoint about
this have you approach the Secretary of
State's office with regards to the
information contained in this
presentation yeah actually um I along
with a lot of others served um a lawful
notice to the Secretary of State and um
he took a meeting with us and um you
know representative uh Panic um and two
other Representatives as well so um he's
very aware of the issue and I think he
was made aware of the issue before we
just did a lawful notice and we met with
him in early
December has he responded in any way or
rebutted the information in any regard
um well during during the meeting he he
debated a few of the points and um his
response was that he thought he was um
that he believed that he was acting
within the Constitution to the best of
his ability um but we did ask him to put
it in writing and he said he could not
um and he has been to to this point
unable to rebut anything we've said zero
he's provided and he in fact sent me a
letter uh saying that he wasn't going to
and I have a copy of
that what's that one more one more last
one
so he he did respond I just want to make
sure I understand what you just stated
he responded to you saying he wasn't
going to acknowledge any of this or can
you explain that response a little bit
more dur during our meeting he responded
orally uh to the notice which we
requested written you know written Point
BYO rebuttal he did not he responded to
my
affidavit that I sent to him
that um you know detailed what happened
during the meeting saying that he was
not going to take any further
action thank you uh any further
questions rep
salers thank you Mr chair um sorry I'm
late to the party I was at someplace
else but in any case uh house resolution
that we have before us right now that
you talking to do you believe this
will if we could get it to pass will it
solve the problem or we have to do
further something further to resolve
this affida problem because I agree with
you in my time we went from 50 uh
absentee voters to 500 when Co hit and
then that was just to me it was
phenomenal so I I just want your opinion
on that well my my opinion is that the
um a resolution is an acknowledgement of
the notice that we're providing today so
I think that goes a long way in terms of
um you know starting the process do I
think it's going to resolve everything
no I think it's a down payment but
certainly if there are things that can
make some of these statutes which are
not you know do not come before The
Constitution if they can void make them
acknowledge they already are void in my
opinion because they're repugnant to
what the Constitution says so it's more
or less a formality at this point as to
how the legislature follows through and
makes that you know uh generally
accepted amongst the public in
themselves so I yeah we if we've already
gone to the ex a branch and you know
they're ignoring us uh the legislature
ignores us and you know perhaps I I
heard mention that you know there's a
there's a individual rights case on this
issue with the Supreme Court okay so
that's all three branches of government
if we can't get this
resolved where are we we're doing
everything we can peacefully all three
branches of government are going to
ignore it we can't do that anymore I'm
afraid that the you know there is there
is actually an instruction in the
Constitution as to what happens when all
three branches of government ignore you
it's not a good
result thank
you any further questions seeing none
thank you for your
testimony thank
you still
there we'll go here uh chair recognizes
Andrew
noise
um two
minutes in support of the
bill welcome to legislative
Administration thank you good morning my
name is Andrew noise I am in support of
this resolution I'm one of the people
coming of my own right I'm not
representing any firm or
group the input from the clerk
um was a bit telling but frankly I think
that his statement actually contradicted
itself and that is the primary source of
Authority for everything that's going to
be discussed in this room and here in
this city is the
Constitution and so while Masons May
State one way or another what should or
should not be discussed when there's an
individual rights case the fact still
stands that the constitution says what
it says and has said so for quite some
time and this resolution is
simply calling the
legislature back to that and that is in
part one article 11 and part two article
32 it's very plainly
stated uh what the requirements are for
a lawful election and so whatever is
debated
here it really doesn't matter matter if
it doesn't comport to the Constitution I
think that we all would agree that if
there was a matter before the courts
about the constitutionality of murder
and there was murder happening out in
those streets that it wouldn't it
wouldn't matter what the resolution did
or didn't say if it said the
Constitution very plainly says that the
people in New Hampshire have a right to
life then we have to go stop that and
whatever was granted to the legislature
to make that happen needs to happen yest
yest part two article 32 very plainly
states the requirements for human
eyewitnesses to observe and count the
votes the leap from that to a machine
and one of the prior gentlemen uh went
into detail about some of some of the
the inw workings of those machines the
leap to a complex machine is very far
are from the human eyewitnesses and it's
not the job of the legislature it's not
the job of any executive or judicial
members to decide that that human
eyewitness now means a
machine um frankly I think it's it's
kind of ridiculous and I think that
everybody in this room needs to remember
that the testimony from the clerk
earlier was referring to Mason's manual
which
says that the constitution stands on a
higher plane which of course comports
with legislative procedure to consider
the Constitution before anything
else to ask this simple question does
part one article 11 and part two article
32 excuse
me clearly State the human
requirements for conducting an
election if so the the question has
already been answered then and the
matters set forth in this resolution are
really self-explanatory and and need to
be acted on
immediately that's
all thank you for your testimony would
you be willing to take questions if
there are any yes are there
any rep
Pearson it's a two-parter because it
requires a let's start with the first
one do you know where the largest
polling place in the United States is
single polling place
it's in Derry my
district we have
18,9 35 registered
voters what happens if I can't get
people to hand
count my ballots are my constituents now
not afforded their right to vote and
have their vote
counted again again I think think that
the that the question is avoiding the
initial imperative and obligation that
you have as a representative to lawfully
carry out elections though though we are
you're not answering my question you're
not answering my question I am answering
your question though because you swore
an oath to the Constitution of the State
of New Hampshire which clearly states
the
requirements electronic voting machines
are not those requirements if we want to
amend the Constitution everybody in this
room I assume knows the simple lawful
means to do that but as it stands now
the Constitution plainly
states how those are to be counted so
while we are all of course sympathetic
to the fact that that might take more
work you have to figure that out and you
can discuss how you're going to have
those double the amount of in places get
more eyes are they have to be human eyes
if you want to if you want to talk about
the expediency of the process that has
to occur within the lawful
constitutional bounds placed on you as a
representative so as far as whether
those count they must count again part
one article 11 clearly states that they
have to be count and that the people
have a right to be represented through
their vote
but as far as the burden on on on those
workers in
Dairy while sympathetic to it you you
have to figure out how to do that in the
lawful bounds set forth in the
Constitution so so what happens to to
answer it directly in a nutshell what
happens is you figure
out how to count those votes by hand
though it may take a long time the
representatives and the individual
officers and
clerks who swear and oath to do this job
have to know that sometimes it's it's
going to be hard work that cannot ever
Trump what the Constitution
says thank you any other questions
thanks for your testimony appreciate
it
I see a similar
name Christopher
noise similar Town similar amount of
time call Christopher
noise uh six welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Mr chair
question representative
he was asking if he could go last is
that possible
um it we have we have these laid out the
way we're going thank you sorry about
that I didn't hear you did you ask me
that oh no I did not hear that
sorry Mr noise yes so my name is Chris
noise I am residing in Bethlehem New
Hampshire and I'm just here as one of
the people to speak to the issue um I
support the
bill um
essentially um oh let me back up and say
that it's my understanding that a
resolution operates similar to a bill if
it were to pass the house it would need
to pass the Senate and the governor
would have to sign off on it in order
for it to be binding but at that point
it is binding every bit is binding as a
bill so these claims that the resolution
is meaningless or non-binding or just a
virtue signal um I don't see any written
evidence of that
anywhere uh so I disagree with that so I
do believe that it's worth trying to
walk through the process just like a
bill the reason why it's better than a
bill is
because bills add on layers of statutes
to the fundamental law and that has what
is exactly what has gotten us into the J
we're in now and so this resolution
rather than attempt to add more layers
of peels to the
onion strips away all the statute which
is in Conflict currently with the
existing articles of the
Constitution
so
um
the the the aspect of the human
eyewitness has been brought up and the
reason why that's important is because
if there's to be a challenge
to the count in the election and
somebody would like to take that to
court for
instance two or more eyewitnesses are
required to establish a fact in law and
the Machine precludes that ability for
the humans to do that so the founding
generation they understood that they
understood law very well and they
understood that two or more eyewitnesses
are required to establish a fact in law
so they placed the clerk the moderator
and a select board
witnessing with their own eyes the
sorting and Counting of the
ballots the benefit of that is like I
said if there's a challenge to the vote
any one of those humans can be placed
under penalty of perjury put on the
stand and ask to testify and they have
the fear of the law in them to know that
if they're caught lying they could spend
time in prison a machine though it may
be able to count and sort as well as a
human being does not have the ability to
get on a on a witness stand and testify
to what it has seen nor is it afraid of
spending time in jail I think that's
pretty ludicrous
right um
so the the other aspect to this is that
the
legislature um is not granted Authority
anywhere that I can find in part two
frame of government to amend or alter a
constitutional provision the only lawful
way to amend or alter a constitutional
provision is through part to article 100
um at a banal election where the
proposal is made to the people and the
majority of the people vote whether they
agree or disagree with an alteration to
the amendment as it stands Today part
two article 32 for instance has never
been amended by the people so all
Alterations by legislature are
unauthorized null and
void
um as to the affidavit
um that was covered briefly and the part
that I think I would like to fill in
there is the very definition of anavit
as seen in Blacks Law Dictionary shows a
sworn officer of the Court verifying the
identity of the
voter um and also uh shows the the sworn
officer of the Court verifying the
identity of the person who comes before
them
well the current situation with
affidavits cuz I was at that meeting
with the secretary of state and I posed
to him this this understanding that the
affidavit needs to be conducted in front
of a sworn notary of the Court that's
the whole point of it is to author is to
verify the authentic the uh identity of
the voter and also the statute calls for
them to witness the voter filling out
the ballot um and the Secretary of State
replied to me well the voter can sign on
the on the affidavit themselves
self-certifying that they are who they
say they are and send it in but that
defies the very definition in Black's
Law Dictionary fourth edition of what an
affidavit is so there's a clear
deficiency
there
um let's
see what else do I need to speak
to I had wanted to go last so I could
kind of tie up any loose send but um
does anybody have any
questions okay well I'll speak to I'll
speak to convenience like as as Andrew
Noy said my son I'm very proud of him um
as he so apply stated um convenience
cannot be a consideration when each one
of you already promised in advance by
way of oath part two article 84 says you
accepted the trust and the New Hampshire
Constitution is a trust IND denture we
are the gr tours you are the trust these
you already promised us that you would
fulfill the contractual terms
I'm not sure if you're all aware that
it's an actual contract like in Vermont
part one article six actually says all
government agents are the people's
trustees and accountable to them in a
legal way so you already promised to us
contractually that you would fulfill the
exact terms of the contract now in an
Express trust contract only what is
expressly written is authorized or
granted Authority and what is not is
expressly written is not authorized for
example let's say I have a trust fund
and I invite you to be one of my
trustees to identify cash flowing real
estate properties and I offer you $2,000
compensation for each one you find and
you agree to be one of my trustees and
you come into contract with me one day a
month down the road we're having coffee
and you show up in a Ferrari and I say
that's a beautiful car where'd you get
the money and you say well I bought it
with the trust fund money helps me get
to the rental estate real estate
properties to buy them quicker for you
and I say well where does it say in the
trust that you could do that and you
said if you replied to me it doesn't say
I couldn't do it I think you could you
can see we'd have a problem and that in
court of law you would be held
responsible for your fiduciary duty well
in New Hampshire Constitution part 232
it shows three human beings sorting and
Counting the votes and it doesn't say
anywhere in there that you can add in a
monkey counting them on the moon you can
no more add a monkey counting them on
the moon than you can add a machine you
don't have that Authority so all along
this whole time the machines have been
unauthorized you promised us that you
would do it exactly the way it says in
part two article 32
and this resolution would strip away
those statutes which you were
unauthorized to make bring us back to
the original operating principle where
we would have our eyewitnesses if we
need them to testify in court to any
miscount or Tom
Foolery um
and as far as the convenience factor um
as representative mcarter has said
that's actually the job of the
legislature is to figure out that type
of detail and you can write statute for
how many polling stations you would be I
mean a very practical solution would be
to double the amount of polling stations
and have enough workers in there to to
count the votes so you could take that
18,000 however many votes are counted in
each one you could take that down um
that's just a practical I'm not saying
that is the solution but I think it's
just to show that it'd be pretty easy to
probably come up with a
solution um but once again convenience
can never be used as an excuse to not
follow the law that you already promised
to
follow thank you thank you we're proud
of your son as
well um Mr chair I just want to a point
of clarification here because it's now
been stated three
times that this statements are being
made that this is like a
bill and this is a non-actionable house
resolution and I think we're getting
away from the that that that clear fact
understood thank
you chair recognizes uh Daniel
Richard indicates 10 minutes be nice if
it was less than that um supports the
bill and has written testimony I
have welcome Mr Richard thank you ladies
and gentlemen of the committee it's my
honor to be here today um my name is
Daniel Richard I'm citizen of New
Hampshire representing myself on uh and
I'm for this bill or this resolution
what I'd like to speak to you today is
uh something different that what
everyone else has talked about so let me
begin with um I'm a constitutional
scholar and I'm here today to share with
this committee the relevant and recent
decisions of the state supreme court and
the Supreme Court of the United States
and how these cases will affect this
legislature moving forward I believe the
subject matter raised by the recent
court rulings are not only important
because they affect the making of law by
this legislature over those specific
subjects but also because it affects the
way the legislature must act in the
future in all legislative
matters those excuse me those cases
include the New Hampshire Supreme Court
recently decided in Brown versus
Secretary of State over the
redistricting fight which cites the
recent Supreme Court decision in morvi
Harper decided in June of this year and
that's really the heart of what I want
to get into because it has a dramatic
effect on all 50
states and it was over the redistricting
conflict morvi Harper is not just about
how election laws must be written but
morvi Harper also addresses the rules
now controlling judicial review by the
state and federal courts which now
affects all 50 states the other recent
cases are the two Federal Second
Amendment cases the District of Columbia
versus heler and New York State Rifle
and Pistol Association versus bruan in
2002 both cases have corrected the
standard of of review which now must be
used used in all the courts including
the state
legislature when all of your federal
protected rights are implicated the
plain text and that's what this court
the Second Amendment cases were all
about as soon as the plain text of the
any legislative act that you go to move
forward if it imp implicates any one of
your enumerated Federal rights you now
have to prove the burden of proof shifts
to the government and that's a radical
departure from past uh be past standards
of review where the uh the move party
would have to prove standing in the
court and so that's that deals
specifically those cases dealt
specifically with the Second Amendment
but what happened in bruan excuse me
what happened in the bruan decision is
that
the uh the court because the lower
courts were not getting the Second
Amendment case from DC correct they were
not applying the proper standard or
review heler clarified it heler went on
to say that any time you're dealing with
any any one of your ferally protected
rights that's any of them this standard
of review now applies so this is
important from a legislative perspective
and within the body of this committee
you now have oversight as to how your
how this body functions how the
legislature functions so that's why I
wanted to bring these things to your
attention Okay I want to get into uh
quotes from the court to deal with the
subject matter and the first one is the
Second Amendment case where reaffirming
what I just said to you about the
standard of review applying to all the
cases we are this is Justice John
Roberts I believe we re reiterate that
the standard for applying the Second
Amendment is as follows when the second
amendment's plain text covers an
individual's conduct the Constitution
presumptively protects that conduct the
government must then justify its
regulation by demonstrating that it's
consistent with the nation's historical
tradition of firearms regulation only
then may the court conclude that the
indiv idual conduct Falls outside of the
Second Amendment its unqualified command
and again this was reiterated in bruan
citing heler the Second Amendment
standard also and this is where it
applies to all of your rights the second
amendment applies excuse me the Second
Amendment standard Accords with how we
protect other constitutional rights take
for instance the freedom of speech in
the First Amendment to which heler
repeatedly comp compared to the right to
keep and be arms in that context quote
when the government restricts speech the
government Bears the burden of approving
the constitutionality of its actions and
again this committee having oversight
over how this legislature functions I
felt this was pertinent for you to
understand more V Harper on the other
hand is the redistricting fight that
came down late uh six months ago
approximately morvi Harper explores the
meaning of the election Clause the
federal election Clause Article 1
Section 4 Clause one of the Federal
Constitution requires the legislature of
each state to prescribe the rules
governing Federal elections the election
Clause of the Federal Constitution
Article One Clause excuse me Article 1
Section 4 Clause 1 is a fundamental
right of the people and is expressly
requires of the New Hampshire
legislature that it shall prescribe the
times places and Manner and manner is
key that is the process and that's what
this is now affecting it's now going to
affect how the legislature must deal
with with
legislation with the restrictions that
are now part of this court so let me
continue because of this the this power
is specific and it's mandatory it cannot
be delegated the legislature cannot
delegate its authority to make law for
example to the ballot law commission
this is a big problem the New Hampshire
Supreme Court in its recent decision in
Brown versus Secretary of State in New
Hampshire redistricting case cites the
North Carolina redistricting case morvi
Harper and and in that in that decision
Justice uh Donovan recently wrote citing
Mor V Harper explaining in Congressional
redistricting case the Supreme Court has
an obligation to ensure State Court
interpretations of state law do not
evade federal law and again that was
just recently cited by the state supreme
court making Mor V Harper now State
president in my opinion the argument
Advanced excuse
me moving on to the Court's opinion on
this subject nothing in the election
clause instructs nor has this court ever
held that the state legislature May
prescribe regulations on the time plac
in manner holding Federal elections in
defiance of provisions of the State
Constitution that's critical they're
making the point that the state
legislature is bound by its written
document and he goes on to say quote the
argument Advanced by the defendants in
this case and The Descent also does not
account for the framer's understanding
that when the legislature makes laws
they are bound by the provisions of the
the very document that give them life
legislatures as the framers recognized
quote are mere creatures of the state
constitutions and they cannot be greater
than their creators what are legislator
creatures of the Constitution they owe
their existence to the Constitution and
they derive their powers from the
Constitution it is their commission and
therefore all acts must be conformable
to it or else they'll be void Marberry
confirmed this understanding and nothing
in the text of the election Clause
undermines it when a State Legislature
carries out its constitutional power to
prescribe rules regulating Federal
elections the commission under which it
exercises Authority is twofold citing
Federalist number
78 the legislature acts as both a
lawmaking body created and bound by its
state constitution and as an entity
assigned particular authority of the
Federal Constitution both constitutions
control and restrain the legislature's
exercise of power and finally the last
couple of points here the The Descent
back to the Supreme Court here Arizona
just as a sidebar Arizona in uh a few
years back decided to take from the
Arizona legislature the ability to
redistrict because Arizona's
Constitution just like ours ours in
article 26 and article 65 of part two
clearly established and that's what the
state supreme court just reaffirmed a
month ago that because the Constitution
prescribes that the state legislature is
responsible for redistricting the courts
have no business telling the legislature
what to do so in that case they also
expounded on Arizona Arizona amended its
Constitution properly and created a
redistricting commission it's got
problems they were already suing each
other the legislature is suing the
redistricting commission you already
have that as a proposed cacr before this
before the body now I think it's cacr 19
but making the final points here on this
on that issue Arizona State Legislature
excuse me The Descent reads Smiley in
the Arizona State State Legislature In a
Different Light Justice Thomas thinks
those cases say nothing about whether a
state can impose substantive limits on
the legislator's ex exercise of power
under the election Clause but in Smiley
we addressed whether the conditions
which attached to the making of state
laws apply to the legislator's exercise
of Authority Under the election Clause
we held they do much that is urged in
argument with regard to the meaning of
the term legislature we explained is
beside the point and we concluded in
straightforward terms the legislature
must abide restri by the restrictions
imposed by the state constitutions and
when restrict when exercising the
lawmaking power under the election
Clause citing the Arizona State
Legislature said much the same
emphasizing that by this text nothing in
the election Clause offers the state
legislator's cart blanch to act in
defiance of the State
Constitution and I'll move to the state
constitution part two Article 5 the very
instrument that gives you your Authority
very old case still stands today Merill
versus Sherburn 1818 which said the
following that clause which is referring
to part two Article 5 which confers upon
the general court the authority to make
laws provides at the same time they must
not be repugnant or contrary to the
Constitution so my closing points are we
have a big problem now the ballot law
commission no under these precedents the
ballot law commission no longer has
Authority to authorize the towns to use
voting machines which is now illegal not
because I say so it's because the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has just
Incorporated Mor V Harper where this is
argued before the federal Supreme Court
and finally I'm the one bringing the the
action before the court now over many of
these illegal changes to our election
laws that I believe are unconstitutional
but let me quote Justice McDonald who
when if you if you want to balance where
you think this case is at please go see
the oral arguments you're going to see
that the state did not do a very good
job defending itself and Gordon McDonald
chief justice McDonald said a brilliant
question he POS this question this is
what I want you to remember quote
permissible legislative judgment this is
he's asking the state's attorney this
permissible legislative judgment I don't
understand what that term means how is
it permissible legislative judgment
permissible if it exceeds the authority
of the
Constitution brilliant they were
prepared thank you questions
I don't know um are there
questions representative
mcarter thank you Mr Richards for coming
today and speaking um on this house
resolution there's uh a state that's a
neighboring state of ours Massachusetts
has a very similar Constitution is in in
your experience I understand that you're
you're a very studied man with regards
to the New Hampshire Constitution are
you aware of of um the similarities to
our constitution as Massachusetts has
and how they have voting machines in
Massachusetts could you could you speak
to that or or not yeah absolutely um
really straightforward John Adams wrote
The Seven the Massachusetts constitution
in 1780 New Hampshire was actually the
first of all 13 colonies to write a
constitution but it was very defective
there was one chamber so we go through
the Revolutionary War on the other side
New Hampshire had the great Fortune to
look at the other 12 that had gone into
effect During the Revolution and wrote
our constitution predicated on theirs
the courts always look with great
interest over opinions or changes to the
function of a sister States next door
especially because of that genealogy and
uh in this case Massachusetts had the
same provision about part two article 32
that requires three human beings to to
conduct the election process the
moderator is supposed to sort and count
the vote he's supposed to to examine the
ballots and declare the count how can he
declare the count if he actually didn't
count the ballots the clerk the clerk
has a duty to not conduct his own
certification or his own count but
rather to witness the process and then
certify that he witnessed the moderator
sort and count vote and remember there
was no electricity in
1784 the courts are very clear on this
you're not going to get a court anywhere
in the 50 states to say anything other
than when we look at an any anything to
do with our state or federal
constitutions we look at original intent
what did they mean and so back to the
answer Massachusetts put it on the
ballot they put it on a referendum and
that's what I advocate here you know the
Beauty and the genius of our form of
government is the ability to alter it
and I got to tell you I'm a I'm an
independent I vote Republican but I'll
tell you this the Democrats are smart
about some things okay and one of them
is they hire good lawyers and what are
they all doing about the lack of
progress they're making over is issues
the redistricting fight what did they do
there they lost twice it was it was
vetoed so now they're putting a cacr
abortion is another great issue right
why did why did it get struck down it's
because it wasn't a constitutional right
so now what are they doing they're
preparing a constitutional amendment and
so to all the Grievances uh that I that
I am against in my in my brief in my
lawsuit is all the same problem it's all
failure to follow the process because
we're guaranteed a process
hope that answered your question thank
you it's just based on what you just
said it just help me out here that the
moderator is required to count the
ballots sort and count sort specifically
is what's not happening the the
moderator that's a singular person
that's
right okay all right I'll just go back
to my 18,000 935 people being counted
byat let me give you a really good
solution I'd like to answer question if
that's okay um here's the Simplicity of
it the constitution of New Hampshire was
written in 1784 where the population
which much smaller and so it's been
amended a bunch of times along the way
and the on the the proper process at
each step so the solution to your
problem is we need to have some type of
amendment to address the issue like one
of the other gentlemen pointed out if
the legislature needs to pass
legislation to reinforce the local
municipalities to deal with this look
this legisl is going to have to deal
with this problem if it rules and
Strikes these things down real soon like
sooner than later maybe before the the
upcoming election and if they don't have
machines in place and the court strikes
that down they need to put a game plan
together and better to know now than to
find out during the election process but
that's what you need you need an
amendment either a legislative act that
calls more people to serve
or um or or put an amendment on the on
the a ballot measure forward in order to
create or authorize the use of machines
thank you um you mentioned you had
written testimony I did and I've
submitted a copy we do have it I
apologize thank you for your testimony
appreciate
it uh chair will call Trish I'm going to
murder this name I'm sure um Trisha
noala welcome to legislative
Administration you indicate you're
representing
yourself and and supporting the bill and
asking for three
minutes yes that's correct how' I do on
the name um no yeah I thought so it's
okay I answer to most
things could you introduce yourself and
uh and that you support the bill and
where you're
from Good Morning house
committee my name is Trisha
naalu I am representing myself in my
community I'm from stratum New
Hampshire and I wanted to support this
because throughout my career I have used
an alias and in fact most of the
community I work with uses another name
for safety
precautions I am the founder of erotic
laborers Alliance of New England we
offer resources to consensual adults
engage in sex work and we are an
anti-trafficking
group granting immunity when giving
testimony for certain community members
would increase their sense of safety and
it would encourage more testimony of
their lived
experience oh I'm sorry that may be my
fault um is there oh I put it under here
sorry the card I I assumed did I fill it
out wrong no I did I read it wrong um
you are here talking about uh 1367 1367
correct cor okay we're still in the
hearing for um house resolution 25 sorry
my fault nice meeting you nice meeting
you we'll be back I'll be back thank you
okay good it was like a practice
run it's an imperfect committee I should
say
um with that uh we'll move to um rep
Penza two minutes you've asked
for welcome back thank
you sorry computer won't
open
okay thank you Mr chair my name is uh
representative Kelly bensa raford
District 19 uh which is Rochester Wards
1 2 3 four and six um I'm here to speak
in fully support of house resolution 25
I support this bill because I know that
there is really only one lawful way for
any constitutional provision to be
altered and that is by asking the people
in a banial election year if a majority
of them agree to amend the Constitution
it's pretty simple other than that the
leg ISL does not have any authority to
amend or alter a constitutional
provision I have searched repeatedly and
I cannot find any record of the people
of New Hampshire voting to amend New
Hampshire Constitution part one article
11 nor part two article 32 despite this
lack of evidence showing that that the
people who are the only ones with the
authority to amend a constitutional
provision I do in fact see that New
Hampshire part one article 11 and New
Hampshire and New Hampshire part 2
article 32 have been altered by
legislative um by the legislature via
statute these unlawful acts must be
reversed I'm going to digress just real
quick because of all this testimony
that's happened I don't understand how
how do we pass a bill because this is a
real resolution right so we're out of
compliance so if we're out of compliance
why would we're breaking the law so how
are we going to pass a bill to say don't
break the law so then may we should just
pass a bill that says that so that to me
it's just like a a circular firing squad
but I I digress um so we must now
resolve as a body who are bound by oath
to uphold New Hampshire part one article
11 and New Hampshire part two article 32
to fulfill our fiduciary duty to uphold
the Constitutional Provisions as they
appear expressively written now in our
state constitution which is a trust and
denture contract which is mentioned of
course in this resolution voters are the
granters I as an elected official I'm
the grantee in a sense the voters are
their trustees I is an elected official
and responsibility for protecting the
trust the contract in essence the
representatives are the employees to the
citizens of New
Hampshire unless any one on this
committee or anywhere else in this you
know legislative body possesses evidence
that there was in fact a vote by the
people to amend the Constitutional
Provisions as seen in New Hampshire part
1 article 11 in New Hampshire part two
article 32 then I need to see that
evidence and it needs to be placed into
the express writings of those Provisions
because as it stands today the express
written Provisions do not make allowance
for any machines and machines have been
talked about a lot
and um I'd really like to focus on the
absentee ballot piece because that is
the huge one that is that has changed
since 2020 moving forward by percentage
increases in a town at at the time I was
living in Rye uh the absentee ballot
rate was less than 10% it went up to
over 30% we had over 100% voter turnout
that can't be when it's never been more
than 65% these are things that to me the
absentee ballot process which for in the
Constitution the only two ways that you
can vote if you are absent from the city
or town of which you are inhabitant or
by reason of physical disability and are
enable to vote in
person that to me is is uh is so crucial
and I don't know if that's really been
talked about a lot today so
um where am I at so for these these
reasons uh hr25 in necessity in order
for the legislature to provide a path to
come back into compliance uh with
constitutional Provisions controlling
the parameters of elections in New
Hampshire um I I hope that uh you take
I'm I'm glad that you gave us all this
time I appreciate all the thoughtful
questions and um that's
it thank you for your testimony are
there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much um appreciate you hanging around uh
last pink card I have is for Brian Gould
um indicating he's speaking for himself
and asking for five minutes and is
opposed to the
bill welcome Mr
Gould sorry that's better uh thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee
uh my name is Brian Gould I'm a lawyer
here in conquer I practice with
Cleveland Waters and bass two streets
over um I practiced law in New Hampshire
about 35 years um over the course of my
career I've regularly litigated
constitutional U matters um which is
unusual because I'm a civil litigator
not a con criminal litigator they deal
with constitutional issues frequently
but in the Civil context not quite as
much um to give you a couple of quick
examples I was uh the lawyer for the
governor and executive counsel uh when
the legislature attempted to modify the
statute that would dictate who the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court would be
and we prevailed on an original petition
before the uh before replacement
justices on the New Hampshire supreme
court because they were all recused
because it affected all of them um but
we prevailed in that case and uh the
court the reconstituted Court held that
uh there that the legislature had
violated the separation of powers and
had violated the Constitution uh by
attempting to intervene in how the Chief
Justice was selected another case in
which I worked was at more recently was
the Senate Bill 3
litigation uh I know the chairman is
very familiar with that um because I
believe he delivered the committee
report on the floor
uh for the election law committee uh
supporting that bill I was retained by
the state of New Hampshire to supplement
the uh represent the defense of that
bill by the Attorney General's office I
represented the attorney general who at
that time was Gordon McDonald and the
Secretary of State who at that time was
Bill Gardner in that case and we tried
that case and eventually it was taken up
to the New Hampshire Supreme Court and
the bill was struck down the reason I
mention this is because um over the
years I've developed um a fair amount of
experience with election law um I'm not
at the level that say Bud Fitch is um
you know bud is is sort of encyclopedic
uh on those things over at the U
secretary's office but I have had a fair
amount of u of dealing with these
cases those of us uh and and I count
myself among them who favor increasing
the Integrity of our elections have to
face some facts though um because these
issues end up getting resolved in the
courts and so it's not a matter of
theory it's a matter of experience what
have we learned from the courts in New
Hampshire over the
years um one thing that we can that we
can say with with some certainty is that
the courts uh look very skeptically on
changes in law that restrict ballot
access from what it is
currently so you start at a disadvantage
to the extent that you're trying to cut
back on uh ballot
access and that
is sort of an overarching principle here
is if you think about it there's tension
between the desire to uh to ensure that
only qualified voters can pull a
ballot and the the uh the burden that's
placed on voters uh their right to vote
because if you are going to restrict
access you're going to say I'm going to
impose these these
qualifications you
are uh necessarily excluding some voters
as unqualified and the question becomes
is that necessary to protect against um
unqualified voters voter and that's the
balancing that the courts
undertake
um another observation is and and this
is why I decided to come today because
it's not so much the underlying policy
that's being promoted by this but the
vehicle by which um this is being
proposed because aside from the language
of any Amendment to the
rsas probably in an election law case
probably the most important
factor uh is whether the new restriction
uh the most important factor in
determining whether the new restriction
survives judicial scrutiny is
legislative
history um if any inflammatory or
eccentric language in legislative
statements not that that would ever
happen but um whether it's in the bill
in committee on the floor make the
defense of the new language very
difficult as an example in the Senate
Bill 3 case um the plaintiffs uh who
were the Democratic party and um a
national uh super pack had uh become
involved and and recruited some
Plains but they focused on the fact that
some people even just lobbyists had
testified that the reason for this bill
was to prevent college students from
voting in New Hampshire elections and
the bill did nothing about the kind but
because that was in the legislative
history and showed a certain hostility
to a certain class of voter uh the court
the the Superior Court seized on that as
evidence that this uh bill
was intended to restrict votes without
an an appropriate
basis
and I know that house resolution 25
doesn't actually amend anything of it
sounds like there's some debate about
that but if it were to pass and
legislation were enacted actually
enacted that is consistent with the
objectives of uh house resolution
25 the resolution itself will be part of
that legislative record if if the bill
is challenged on uh in the courts and I
I believe that several parts of this
resolution will make future consistent
amendments to the statutes that is
regarding ballots and U voting machines
uh more far more difficult for the
Attorney General's office to
defend um for example you heard a
reference to the Constitution as being a
trust instrument there is one reference
to trust in part two I think it's
article 84 of the of the Constitution
but the Constitution does it doesn't
itself say that it is a trust instrument
so the reasoning that flows from that
assertion in this um in this resolution
would be viewed I think as um it's
interesting intellectually but I think
the courts would view it as an eccentric
point of view which harms your ability
to defend the the
legislation um this resolution relies on
16th century maxims of law from Lord
cook and uh Sir Francis Bacon uh both of
whom were controversial in their time
this was before the the uh the pilgrims
sailed for the new world that they were
uh positing these maxims under English
law I can honestly say I've never seen
the New Hampshire Supreme Court cite one
of these maxims they may have at some
point but it's not likely to be very
persuasive at all and to include
something that is that unusual in the
legislative findings and recitations
makes it very difficult to defend the
merits of any uh change in the law that
you might uh
enact
um Mr Richard testified about his
understanding of the bruan decision um
and I understand I understand what he's
trying to say about that but I think
what
he's and the reason it's important is
it's in the
resolution that's a very aggressive
reading of bruan that it now eliminates
the mean means ends testing you may have
heard of strict scrutiny intermediate
scrutiny rational basis tests these are
all tests the courts use to determine
whether a burden on a constitutional
right is uh lawful um and the court did
Express skepticism about that in bruan
but that case is limited to the Second
Amendment the court has not said that
it's dispensing with that altogether so
for this legislature to to accept that
reading of Bruin before The Supreme
Court has said that it applies across
the board and before the New Hampshire
Supreme Court has said anything about
whether it will follow Bruin for matters
of State constitutional rights Again
undermines The legislator's credibility
with the courts and it's very important
if you're going to undertake these kind
of policy changes in the election law
context that you have that level of
credibility um there are citations to a
number of authorities in this resolution
none of them uh to an opinion of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court Justices or an
opinion of the new yire supreme court
itself um and in fact that's important
because during the Civil
War our court uh the justices took up a
a a statutory change to allow the uh The
Men Who were fighting for us in the
Civil War to vote remotely and our
Supreme which all of us I think would be
generally sympathetic to Supreme Court
said no the sup the the Constitution at
that time did not allow for absentee uh
balloting of this kind and they didn't
allow it there was a few years later
there was a a fix that did get past the
court um but my point is there is New
Hampshire Authority but that's not cited
in this resolution which is a red flag
to court that you know you're not even
relying on established New Hampshire law
as the basis for this
resolution um and then finally there's a
reference in here to the uh people
having what's called inum jurisdiction
over legislators again a very eccentric
way of putting the concept that the
legislature is generally answerable to
the people uh to courts in Persona Juris
ition refers to the ability of the court
to exercise authority over a party
before it so to use that term in this
context is jarring and so my point in
all of this
is I'm I'm not here to talk about you
know whether voting machines are a good
idea or a bad idea or um you know the
scope of absentee balloting although I
think the new supreme court and the
justices have made pretty clear what the
law on that is
but it is it is critical if you're going
to go down this path that whatever it is
that you pass is credible with the
courts because that's where it's going
to end up and so if you care about the
outcome any of these references to um
obscure areas of law and the sort of
theorizing should be very very carefully
vetted because you don't want to pass
something that the courts read and say I
don't even know what this means this
none of this language makes sense to me
I can't relate to it it's not something
on which I would
rely so that's that's my testimony um
thank you very much for listening thank
you for your time appreciate it would
you be willing to take a question or two
oh
sure are there a question I thought
there might um representative
mcarter thank you Mr chair to see you
again you too thanks for coming today um
I just have a quick question and uh I
would suspect you have the answer can
you point me to where I can find uh in
our constitution where we have to wait
as legislators or the legislature as a
whole where we would have to wait for
the courts to point out that we have uh
created statute and error or we have
made a mistake and we need to fix that
mistake can you
Define that for me because I'm having a
hard time with that if that's if that's
the impression I left you with then
that's my error I did not mean to imply
that you have to wait for the courts
what I'm saying is that if you modify
statutes the predicate on which you
modify those statutes will be relevant
to a review by the courts of whether
that change in law is
lawful um the legislature has an in has
independent authority to determine
whether a statute is unlawful or
unconstitutional in the first place it
can certainly do that but if the result
of that determination is that you're
going to restrict access to the
ballot that raises a significant issue
in the minds of the courts we have a lot
of indications most recently probably in
the in the Senate Bill 3 decision ision
but based on the GU uh
decision um that the courts are going to
look very carefully at a change in law
that makes it harder to to get a ballot
that doesn't mean it won't uphold it but
you have to understand you're going into
those cases with the court being very
skeptical and that's the that's the
battle that I'm trying to um point out
to this committee is the one you need to
think about winning because you can pass
anything but the courts have the
authority to declare what you pass
unconstitutional and to get past that I
think you need to build a sort of a
better record than I think this
resolution does that answers your
question um can I just follow on that
point a
bit is it the fact of being a resolution
that the court would question or um does
that matter I don't I don't think it
matters I mean I'm not going to jump
into the debate over whether a
resolution is effective I think
representative Pearson made the point
that um that it is a resolution and
therefore is not binding law I think
that that's my understanding of a
resolution I'm thinking longer term
because if the legislature wants to
change these policies on voting machines
and absentee ballots it's going to have
to enact legislation to change the
law this resolution containing as it
does a certain rationale for that
becomes
evidence when that later bill is
challenged because it's part of you know
I've heard people say this resolution
sort of sets the table for
legislation if that's true then that
means if there's a challenge to it this
resolution becomes part of the
legislative record and if there's
something in the legislative record that
makes the courts look a scance at what
the legis was thinking that makes it
much more difficult to defend the
lawfulness of that later legislation so
that the short answer is no the fact
that it's a resolution doesn't matter
it's the
content thank you representative
sers thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm trying to
understand something you're saying there
that how does this
resolution exclude voters or restrict
the ballot access if it's requiring the
government to follow the
Constitution and I I understand and I'm
very sympathetic personally to that what
I'm trying to get across is
this the challenge to laws that restrict
access to the ballot are are evaluated
against what is the current state of the
law so even if you've gone if you've
gone
beyond uh what the Constitution requires
and so you're passing a law that you
think brings it back within uh
constitutional
boundaries you're still restricting
access to the ballot from what it
was right that's the whole point and
what I'm trying to say is when the
legislature tries to restrict
access the courts look skeptically at
that it doesn't mean that the court
won't uphold it but the court looks
skeptically at the legislature trying to
restrict access because remember I
talked about there's a balance between
the right to vote and this
legislature's absolutely legitimate
interest which I defended at length and
almost get to the point where I was out
of breath in the Senate Bill 3 case I'm
very sympathetic to that but those two
things are intention and when push comes
to shove the courts tend to favor the
access to the ballot piece so I just
want you to understand what I'm
suggesting is that the the fact that
you're trying to bring it back into
balance with what the Constitution
requires that's a legitimate thing to do
but understand that when you're cutting
back on sort of the liberality of access
to the ballot the courts are skeptical
of that and you have to take that into
account in what you put in the record to
justify that
change anyone
else rep
Mard thank you Mr chair so are you
suggesting that um we need to be as
legislate as legislators we need to be
mindful of a
perceived uh opposition from
courts uh when we're looking to
Institute legislation or or or get
statute through that would be 100%
constitutionally afforded ballot access
are you suggesting that because it it
might be uh viewed as um whatever the
term of the day is voter
disenfranchisement or or restricting
ballot
access that that needs to be a
consideration when we're putting forth
um election law uh type proposal that we
need to look at how a Court's going to
view this not how the Constitution does
are you saying that those need to be
weighted evenly one more than the other
can you elaborate a little bit on that
please if you accept the proposition
that there can be disagreement over
whether a law is constitutional I think
we can all agree on that that that there
can be
disagreement then you have to be
concerned because the courts have the
last word on constitutionality at least
under our current system you have to be
concerned that what you pass as
sincerely as you believe it's required
by the Constitution if a majority of the
Supreme Court disagrees with
you then as a legal matter you were
wrong and the Constitution doesn't
provide as you thought it did and what
I'm suggesting is uh this is a matter of
wisdom this is a matter of building the
record so that whatever decision you
make
and I I you know honestly agree with you
that that absentee balloting got out of
control in the in the you know during Co
and so forth and needs to be dialed back
but what I'm saying is build a record
that makes that decision defensible in
the courts it's not because it's my
personal preference that you satisfy the
courts it's the recognition that the
courts are going to determine if there's
a
lawsuit whether that change is is
constitutional so the smart thing to do
is to build the legislative record so
that that is a defensible decision
that's all I'm getting
at further questions I have one um and
and I'll um preface it by saying I
didn't fully understand this so um the
Brewin um
level of scrutiny handled uh mentioned
under
bruan it was said to me earlier in
testimony or it was said to us earlier
in
testimony that because of
bruan the other three methods or levels
of
scrutiny um seem to be washed away by
bruan um can you elaborate on or do you
concur do you disagree do you I I think
I heard you say that Bruin was specific
to Second
Amendment it was but it sounded to me
like the prior testimony was that it was
now going to be something that the
legislature had to take into account um
this new level rather than the prior
three levels well if it's a second
amendment regulation you would have to
take it into account um what what
Bruin I've never liked the different
levels of scrutiny and Justice Thomas's
opinion in bruan really explained why
said you know at least in the Second
Amendment context what we're doing is
yielding power to the courts to make
policy decisions if we allow the courts
to say is this an important policy and
are the means that you chose necessary
or rationally related to that purpose
you you can see how that shifts a lot of
power to the courts and and
Thomas uh gave that idea the back of his
hand and bruan and said at least in the
Second Amendment context what we're
going to focus on
is is the right that's an issue in this
case carrying uh handgun in New York
City is that right uh cons consistent
with the Second Amendment when it was
adopted in the court it was clearly that
people were allowed to carry uh their
their uh
weapons uh in public what the lower
court did is it said okay now that we've
determine that we're going to determine
whether this
restriction is
uh is necessary to achieve this state
policy and the Supreme Court said no
you're not going to do that I all you're
going to do is look at whether that
proposed restriction is consistent with
the kinds of restrictions that were in
place when the second amendment was
adopted and if it is inconsistent then
it's
unconstitutional so bruan
made Second Amendment law very simple
bruan did
not uh revoke this means ends test you
know strict scrutiny intermediate
scrutiny and uh rational basis across
the board Court um a lot of
conservatives have sort of jumped on it
and said oh this signals that the
Court's abandoning
that that's not the way lawyers look at
things until the Supreme Court says and
by the way we're doing away with all
these means and testing we assume that
it's still in place more importantly
under the New Hampshire
Constitution our Supreme Court uses
means ends
testing so unless the issue is a federal
an issue of federal law
and this would be under the State
Constitution which is being argued here
the means ends test is still in place in
New Hampshire there's nothing about
Bruin that changes that for a question
of state
law I don't know if I cleared it up or
made it worse um I'll have to get back
to you
on I'm sorry I appreciate the uh the
answer however um are there any further
questions uh
rep thank you Mr chair and I'll admit
this stuff gets pretty deep and I'm no
expert on it but it uh questions come to
mind and and and thoughts and stuff and
you know didn't in the New Hampshire
Supreme Court uh W Wier I think Wier
versus Plymouth um call the people
granters and therefore don't the
granters aren't the ones aren't they the
ones that create
Trust
I mean if it's already been stated that
where the grant is and the grant is
we're the ones that create a trust isn't
that correct well to some extent it's
just a question of terminology right
because the because the um there's no
question but from from the earliest
articles in the Constitution that the
authority of the legislature comes from
the people through their consent so
that's really
indisputable what I'm saying is that
that the Constitution does not refer to
itself as a trust instrument there is
one reference in the oath section which
is part two article 84 to whether an
officer I think believe the languages
accepts the trust uh as a result of
being
elected but to extrapolate from that to
the entire Constitution is a trust
instrument understand that my point is
not is it in fact a trust instrument my
point is how do the courts look at that
do the courts look at that and say
that's a very eccentric view of the law
that is not some that's not the way we
normally think about this so just be
aware that if you if you choose to go
down that
path have a you know have have a lawyer
look at it and determine whether this is
actually language that's consistent with
the way the courts think about this
stuff because if you don't do that then
when it lands on a judge's desk the
judge says I've never understood this to
be a
trust Okay I lied it wasn't the last
question
um how am I am am I five minutes up yeah
well that was five minutes of testimony
the questions don't add five minutes um
my question is and I'm not going to lose
the opportunity to ask um my question is
how we how this
could have been done differently or
could it have been done differently as
requesting an opinion of the justices
prior yes could you comment on that yeah
and that's the mechanism of course under
our constitution for determining uh
whether um a a statute proposed or
existing um particularly in connection
with legislation that would proport to
change it you could send it to the
Supreme Court and say give us an opinion
an advisory opinion and as to whether
this law uh exceeds the authority uh
granted to the legislature under the
Constitution that's the that's the
straightforward way of doing it um and
you avoid all of the it's it's a much
quicker way of getting an answer and you
don't take the risk that you do with
passing something that's as sort of
Arcane as this resolution run it through
the Superior Court then up to the
Supreme Court you have a quicker answer
and that is the way the Constitution
contemplates that these kinds of issues
would be presented to the
court thank you I think that it does
answer my question but I have to think
that through too um anyone else
yes no that's
fine so thank you again for I'm just
glad I piqued your interest in it you I
you're you you have a lot of information
in your noggin that I probably could
afford to learn from um are you saying
that if we were to send for this house
resolution to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court and ask for an advisory opinion
that that would be a prudent thing to do
no okay I'm saying I don't think this I
don't think this resolution is a good
idea I think if you want to accomplish
the underlying policy goals that is
restricting absentee balloting and
restricting access to machines you ought
to maybe amend this somehow or or put
forward legislation that does that and
ask the court whether existing law
whether this bill is consistent the
proposed bill is consistent with the the
Constitution and whether existing law is
consistent with the Constitution that's
what I'm
saying see that I'm glad you asked that
question thank you um I appreciate it um
I think we appreciate your testimony um
I have no further pink cards right I
think we did for the right bill they
have no other pin cards I'll close the
hearing um on house resolution 25 uh it
is almost perfectly the right
timing um what I would like to do I've
closed the hearing on
hr25 um I would like to
open uh House Bill 16 uh
1367 and recess it to a Time certain or
move it to a Time certain that would be
going to
2:00 and the reason for that is uh the
prime sponsor of that bill as well as
the bill that's due for 140 happens to
be the same time
um what's
that yep
um uh then uh the house bill
19 um will be
rescheduled to um January 31st a hearing
that has yet to for been put into the
calendar um and then we'll move into
this afternoon beginning at
1:00 with House Bill
1309 good with that yeah things that
were mentioned
testimony yeah
um sure if you want to make copies and
and get get this to our clerk that would
be
great or if those are
copies um anything else anyone has for
me before we adjourn for
lunch all right um we're closed to 1:00
uh we have gavel being handed
over um to our vice chair so I'm
admonishing you all to
be
nice thank
you
for
every committee has its
own
good
afternoon it is a little past one we're
going to open up the hearing for um
House Bill 1309 and we have the prime
sponsor here representative Weber if
you'd like to
start thank you madam chair and
committee members uh this bill is um
arises out of concern for transparency
in our governmental
processes and it's something I've been
thinking about for a long time but
haven't gotten to uh but here's the
thing we in the house have deadlines to
get our bills out we know when those are
uh and when they go to the body that is
not supposed to be named they too have
deadlines so we know where the bills are
and what's happening with them and
they're also docketed in our docketing
system so we know what has happened and
what's likely to happen
soon and so a bill passes the house and
it passes the Senate and what happens
then well we all know it goes to the
governor but before it goes to the
governor it gets signed it gets enrolled
and that's a process process and then it
uh goes to the Speaker of the House for
Signature and then it goes to the
president of the senate for Signature
and they have no deadlines and you may
have noticed that some bills don't get
signed till July or August maybe even
and so I know my limits and I didn't
want to interfere with the prerogatives
either of the um speaker of the house or
the senate or the president but I do
want people to know where the bills are
and I will just tell you one small
example I had when I sat on uh
Ed I had a bill that
conformed the statute on Commercial
appraisers in New Hampshire to a federal
requirement and what we had been told in
the hearing which we expedited in
February was that if this bill was not
signed by January 1st all all of the
commercial appraisers would be
desertified for federal
purposes and this was going to have a
terrible problem for a lot of people in
the state of New Hampshire so when we
got to June 28th and the bill still had
not progressed to the governor's
desk um I went to the Secretary of
State's office and said what's happening
with the bill and they said it's at the
Senate president's office and I went to
the Senate president's office and I said
what's happening with the Bill and they
said we don't have it and I went
downstairs to the Secretary of State's
office and I got somebody from the
office to come upstairs and say yes it
is in the Senate president's office and
at that point the way they knew that was
because they had a spiralbound notebook
which was uh cross referenced only by
date as to what Bill had been carried
where by the Secretary of State's office
cuz that office handles passing the
bills around and with some discussion
about how do we let both representatives
and our staff here and members of the
public know where the bills are this
seemed to me to be the easiest way to do
it we had some discussion at some point
I think about trying to include it in
our docket system and that's going to be
a problem with our docket system and the
clerk is here to talk about that um I
know there are issues with the Secretary
of State's website so that's why
I
um uh referenced either the secretar of
state's website or on a public website
linked to its Secretary of State's
website because I thought there might be
something off the shelf that was easy to
install and put up that might be easier
than actually redoing their entire
website
structure so um the choice is up to to
them as to how this is implemented and I
want it to be as flexible as possible I
just want members of the public members
of the General Court members of our
staff uh and anybody who wants to know
to be able to figure out where a bill is
between the time it passes the second
body and gets to the governor's desk so
that's the purpose of this legislation
and I leave it in your competent hands I
I will just signal for the committee I
my understanding was there was a certain
amount of um either sign-ins or
testimony given online for people who
couldn't be here today but thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
will you take
questions are there any questions yes
re thank you madam chair thank you for
uh for your
testimony I
use I I read through this before today
and I was kind of almost appalled that
we actually need to put in
legislation to facilitate something like
this that it's not just a simple it
thing
or whoever the person is you know
someone smarter than me in that space
obviously but there really needs to be
legislation to have them enact or make a
portal for this kind of
stuff I will be the first to admit that
I have had a pretty
um heavyduty extracurricular time of the
last year and so I Poss possibly could
have gone to the Secretary of State's
office and asked them to do this uh I
did not do that and and more shame to me
for not having done that because
certainly they could do this but having
had a lot of experience with um various
agencies within the state many of whom
operate with uh very ancient programs
and and it stuff uh I know that up
updating things and just making a change
is not always the easiest thing to do uh
but I also wanted to be sure we got it
done so I thought whether this bill
becomes a vehicle for a conversation and
a promise or whether this bill becomes
law uh I wanted to be sure that we were
just bringing it forward to everybody's
attention any other questions from the
committee thank you very much thank
thank you for your time it's nice to be
home I'd like to call up um house clerk
Paul
Smith thank you madam chair and members
of the committee for the record Paul
Smith Clerk of the house um as you know
I'm not here to testify in opposition or
supportive legislation however um I'm
just skirting that because this
legislation will be incredibly helpful
to the legislative process it will be
incredibly helpful because for months
between usually
May and sometimes up until
October I'm getting calls from the
public saying this bill passed on March
30th why has this not been put to the
governor Etc and I can't tell them I
can't tell them where the bill is I
can't tell them if it has if it's
stalled in the speaker's office or if
it's stalled in the Senate president's
office but yes they have stalled in
those offices as a matter of fact a
couple of years ago uh a a former Senate
President who is still in the Senate uh
held on to a bill until almost October
and that is a very long time when a bill
passes in June uh just to just to
reiterate the the enrolling process
after a bill passes both bodies it goes
to the office of legislative Services
the office of legislative services at
that time determines if an additional
enrolled Bill Amendment needs to be
drafted an enrolled Bill Amendment uh
usually will fix typos um RSA references
that are incorrect uh effective dates
Etc so that's the purpose of the
enrolled Bill Amendment the enrolled
Bill amendment is then sent to both
bodies the house and the Senate where
the amendment is acted on now as you
know at the end of a regular session of
the house we recess we recess for the
ability to do certain things one of
those things is adopt and ruled Bill
amendments these are ministerial things
these are things that don't require a
full vote of the body to do and so we do
those in recess after the enrolled Bill
amendment is processed it is then
delivered from the office of legislative
services to the Secretary of State's
office the Secretary of State transmits
the bill to the speaker's office for the
speaker
signature once that's done the speaker
sends all of those bills back to the
Secretary of State's office the
Secretary of State then delivers the
bill to the Senate president's office
when those bills are returned then the
Secretary of State processes them to go
to the governor and as you know the
governor has 5 days to sign a bill or
let let it become law without signature
or veto a bill so that's the process in
a nutshell but again this this
legislation will definitely help
increase transparency in the legislature
to represented mccarter's question uh
the answer is yes I do think you need
legislation for this purpose
because in dealing with a
non-legislative body and I'm I'm using
that term generally uh in dealing with a
non-legislative body in in order to make
change in government you
need you sometimes need the sword as
well as the pen and the the sword of
legislation is likely the the way to
make things happen in this case and as
as an administrator in a sense of the
website and the information that goes on
our website um there are certain things
uh for example the the Senate amended
house Bills or the committee of
conference page those are things that I
can up update via
PDF so this is something that the
Secretary of State's office regardless
of whatever Century they may be in may
be able to just update something as
simple as a PDF on their website so uh I
do think to to answer your question that
that it is helpful in this
sense representative wall thank you
madam chairman um this this is um I have
signed bills as chairman of ledge
Administration before because that's
what happens in part of the process is
when the bill goes to the Secretary of
State uh what about OS could the holdup
be down there where where's the snag
occurring do we
know the short answer is I
don't there is a longer answer but we'll
we can have that over coffee
sometime follow follow up okay so this
this bill definitely should help the
process I hope but I'm wondering how we
might find where the real slowdown is
and what we might do to expedite things
through OS representative I do think
that you know obviously OS you have to
remember is handling legislation in in
in all aspects they're dealing with your
floor amendments they're dealing with
committee amendments so they are while
we are also going through the process of
of dealing with bills uh in the
enrolling process we are still actively
acting on legislation on the floor so I
I'm I'm loathed to suggest that OS is is
a holdup here uh this specific
legislation is is just to encourage a uh
a tracking mechanism for once it gets to
the Secretary of State's office which I
think is perfectly
acceptable reprentative
mcarter thank you madam chair so my
understanding is this is only only a a a
portal or or a website um database
however you want to word it that shows
where the bill is in the process it's
not doing anything to rectify the
expediency of the process
correct it doesn't but I I'm not sure
that there is a way to expedite the
process in in that regard
um there are some political
considerations
there are some timing considerations
there there frequently are requests from
the executive to hold a bill for um an
extra week because uh they want to do a
ceremonial signing and inv invite all
the right people Etc so um I'm I'm not
sure that that's a a part of this
conversation any other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you
seeing no one else with a pink card um
oh
yes if you'd like to come up and answer
the question that's
fine thank you for the Indulgence and
thank you for the question it was very
clear to me that if we interfered with
the actual
process this will not this will not
happen but if the members of the public
know where a bill is they know the right
person to call to say what's happening
and that might sharpen people's uh
willingness to move it along or people
might get a very good uh response as to
why what's happening is happening I
didn't want to interfere with the
flexibility I just want to know what's
going on thank
you thank you and uh seeing no other
pink cards uh for House Bill 1309 I'm
going to close uh the hearing for HB
good morning I mean good
afternoon it uh is a little past 1:20
and I'm going to open up the hearing for
HB
1434 and I would like to call the prime
sponsor to the table representative
Moffett thank you
m thank you madam chair good morning and
good afternoon to you too
welcome uh thank you uh for the
record uh I'm representative Mike
Moffett uh representing marac District 4
in the lovely towns of canabury and
Lowden so this measure of 1434 has been
in the mix before uh this version
includes some new language and some
compromises that reflect uh some earlier
testimony and feedback that we have
received uh the flag design is from uh a
National Organization honor and remember
Inc and uh I emailed a photo of it to
this committee uh earlier this morning
uh along with my brief testimony so you
have you should have that and I gave a
hard copy to uh uh representative
Hobson uh so I understand early concerns
about this uh flag potentially did the
the concerns in the past have been the
flag among others concerns uh concerns
about the flag detracting from the
display of existing Flags so hopefully
this latest wording will address those
concerns uh my position is obviously one
of support for the flag and for the
goldar families who seek to have it
recognized here and some of I'm sure
will testify
momentarily uh and some of you know uh
I'm a a big history guy and this type of
initiative helps to keep memories and
Spirits alive of of our fallen uh well
also shining some light on on some
history you know how did we lose them
where did we lose them why did we lose
them so I think there's a lot of value
to the uh flag because of the the
history piece of it that's that's uh
that's me uh and along those lines L um
I'm going to be traveling to Camp
Pendleton California in March for the
dedication of a memorial at Camp
Pendleton Marine base um honoring and
remembering 20 29 29 Marines from my
company Lima 35 who were killed in 1984
40 years ago when the helicopter behind
mine hit a Mountaintop in Korea so the
the idea of of honoring and remembering
people um
resonates and and not just veterans I
think we want to honor and remember all
of our family and friends who we lose
and in different ways and in this case
uh people who've we've lost who wearing
their country's
uniform uh I think particularly deserves
consideration especially during a time
when military recruiting is at a
historic
law uh this type of
recognition uh serves to help I think it
sends an important message that military
service is still valued and that those
who make the ultimate sacrifice will not
be
forgotten uh so this committee now owns
this measure and obviously can further
amend as desired um I will pass on uh
Dan curn of honor and remember New
England sent an email to vetan committee
Vice chair skip Rollins um yesterday
skip representative Rollins sent it to
me
uh pointing out that this measure
specifically if you look at the wording
it specifically mentions National Gold
Star Mothers Day I believe that's in
September uh now the committee could
change that according to uh Dan Colin
you could change it to Gold Star
family's day as opposed to Gold Star
Mother's Day because um they're both the
same day mothers or families that that
type of thing that wording you can
consider if you'd like uh speaking of
Representative Rollins he was hoping to
be here today but he could not uh he U
had to stay at work as some of you know
representative Rollins is a gold star
father uh his son having been killed in
the Middle East um around 20 years ago
he did send me a brief message which I
will read before I conclude here and
this is from representative
Rollins he's the vice chair of State
Federal and Veterans my with the
committee I chair he's my vice
chair uh from represent Rollins I won't
be able to make it as we are short
staffed at work this bill has been a
long time in the making the first couple
of times it was
introduced it had too many days in which
they wanted to fly the flag now it's
been modified to fly only on veteran
related
holidays I feel this bill has a really
good chance to pass this time if we get
it out of the house I know the Senate
and Governor will support it I thought
it would come through our veterans
committee if it had I was going to ask
to do the pi I personally know a lot of
Goldstar families they would really love
to see this pass the biggest fear for
Goldstar families is that Sons and
Daughters will be
forgotten so this bill will go a long
ways to helping them know their losses
won't be
forgotten Skipper
enss so passing it on from Skip and by
the way for those of those of you
watching at home uh Pi Pi means
parliamentary
inquiry uh which is offered just before
house floor vote which helps to uh more
clearly summarize and explain the intent
of a measure just before the house votes
on it as we all know but uh not
everybody maybe knows what a pi is but
uh skip would have wanted or represent
Rollins would have wanted to have done
the pi as a gold star father so that's
all I have thank you for your time and
consideration be happy to try to answer
any questions if the if there are
any thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions from
the committee yes representative wall
thank you madam chairman Madam
chairwoman whatever thank you and thank
you for your testimony and I thank all
the people for being here today gold
star families um has this flag been
created yet has anyone made it do we
know what it's going to look like yes uh
I I I think I mentioned earlier that I
did send the committee a picture of the
flag so uh you can you can uh just go to
email and there's a picture and the flag
varies some some of them have well there
it is uh there you go there it
is those of you watching from home a uh
flag has been and and actually if wow I
don't mean to take over your committee
but if people let watch watching on
YouTube might want to see the flag UHA
to
stand are we allow to do
that hold well there for better worse
there there it
is okay um to answer Upson W's question
there it is yeah I'm seeing it thank you
follow up Madam chairman um yes thank
you um you can take it down now thank
you you can carry it a couple of
questions represent M sure just a couple
quick ones um where else in the country
has this flag been flown do you know
what other states question is uh where
has this flag been flown or approved
elsewhere uh I know it's it's a national
uh incorporation that does this and I'm
going to defer I I I think there's at
least hopefully I see some pink cards so
some of the folks that are going to come
up that are uh part of the movement
could could answer that better than me
thank you very much and final question
if I may please thank you um I know when
we had the PW flag legislation and such
uh there was a lot of question and
concern about when it would be flown
where it would be on the mask and such
um it will be of course below the
American flag how will you display this
sure thank you for the question uh in
the uh legislation I think it
specifically says this would be the uh
the
last in terms of sequence uh American
flag and other flags P flag this one
would be the last one uh in terms of
sequence to be
flown um may I have a final final
question please um my only wonder is you
know not all of us I have a flag pole at
home and I have a couple flags on it
with the order on which this will will
be flown um is it going to be awkward on
and I don't mean to offend anybody
because it's a beautiful flag is how is
this going to be adopted by people with
out llarge flag poles and the fact that
it will be displayed daily and you have
the American flag you have the P flag
you have this how explain that please
sure thank you for the question it's a
great question my understanding is that
that concern has been what has this from
moving forward in the past
uh it's as I read the the legislation
and I'm the prime sponsor as I read the
wording that we move forward uh daily is
is not the issue at this time uh
specifically the flag would be flown at
uh the designated times in the
legislation uh which again you could uh
you could change that you could uh
further uh Define or or limit or expand
or limit the times that it would be
officially uh flown be you know spec I
already mentioned uh Goldstar Mother's
Day or Goldstar family's day in
September that that's in the the wording
but uh you can um do what you will with
it I just have a one question for you um
in doing some research on this bill um I
saw that it has gone uh before the US
House and Senate um and it hasn't picked
up a whole lot of
support and um I'm wondering if you know
why sure uh again the question being why
there has been concerns that this hasn't
moved forward is as so many people would
like you to and um I'll let others speak
to that as well as I said before I'm
sure that the concerns are largely
related to other flags um and this type
of thing we need to be careful in a in
sanctioning or giving official
recognition to any flag or symbol
because uh it it does set preceden and
and there are other Flags uh gosh if you
go to any parade um there were flags for
everything and not all of them can fly
in the state house I know the Marine
Corps flag FES once a year I'm um in the
Marine Corps those of you watching at
home uh Ry so November 10th uh once a
year the marine flag flies but uh to
your point or your question uh I'm sure
that cons there are only so many uh days
and there's only so much room for flags
and so that's part of the issue and the
precedent issue and I and I'm sure
others uh some of these good folks have
been working this for years and years
and they uh could speak to some of the
history and questions better than me I'm
sure thank you is there any other
questions thank you very much for
your I'd like to call up Warren
Perry good afternoon Madam chair members
of the committee for the record my name
is Warren Perry I'm the deputy Adent
General for New Hampshire's Department
of military Affairs and veteran services
we are the department in the state that
does manage and operate the New
Hampshire State Veteran Cemetery in
bosin we do support the bill as a
department uh I think no harm can come
only good can come of supporting the
bill so uh you know there are concerns
about how many flags we fly how many
precedents we set some veterans will
tell you that we have a flag that honors
uh our fallen the American flag you know
and and our fallen our their coffins are
draped with it it's presented to family
members as we go but this particular
symbol will go a long way in helping uh
honor the memory of those who have
fallen so we I would just offer that
that's our support for this particular
uh for this particular Bill uh I think
and I don't know exactly but I think
there are about a thousand gold star
family members in the state of New
Hampshire one way or the other that are
considered Gold Star Family sometimes
the definition can be uh you know were
they actually killed in combat did they
die in training did were they did they
die in the theater of combat operations
not related to combat operations none of
that matters to the family the family
just knows that there is a loss and the
loss is a result of some military
service and and you know when we when we
do things at the cemetery when we have
events at the cemetery replace WS or
flags on the graves of those that are
there we always ask the people that are
participating to read the names on the
on the uh on the on the markers because
a name mentioned or said aloud is never
forgot this flag is another way to
continue to honor that memory I will
tell you that without the legislation
the state Veteran Cemetery in bosin
flies the flag there's already a flag
pole in a mast in our Memorial walkway
that the flag has flown daily there and
we will continue to do so regardless of
the status of this uh you know the the
fate of this bill if you will so pending
that's my short testimony and pending
any questions I'll be I'll happy I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
very much for your testimony are there
any questions from the
committee
runi thank you for taking my question
question I've got for you is the flag
that they showed us that was for a
particular individual yes okay the flag
you fly at bosin is there a name on the
bottom or there no name on the there is
no name on the bottom of that on the
flag that we have at our Cemetery okay
thank you and I would I would just add
just to to say that there everyone in
that Cemetery regardless of their rank
how they died their service is honored
equally so you know the cemetery
director very aptly puts you know when
he's asked who are some of the special
people buried here and he will say there
are 16,000 special people buried here so
we don't single people out there just as
a matter of course sir R Pearson
than you madam chair I'm just uh Curious
on the duration of how long you've been
flying that in
bosin rough roughly it's more than years
so you know that the cemetery is 25
years old I know that we've uh so the
current it was flown before the current
director he's been there for about four
years so I think at least at least six
years maybe
longer it's been
that are there any other questions I I
don't know the exact I caution you just
caveat that I don't know the exact date
but it we didn't just start flying it
when the bill popped up yeah no close
enough seeing no more questions thank
you very much for your
testimony I'd like to call up uh Kevin
Grady who um signed in to oppose this
bill
um it says you need three minutes thank
you welcome to legislative chair ladies
and gentlemen the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady and I'm a
25y year veteran of the Air Force and
I'm a 25 year resident of the town of
hookit New Hampshire uh today I'm here
representing the state veterans advisory
committee and as I don't see this
committee very often and I I see a lot
of unfamiliar faes I'd like to take a
just a a few seconds to say what it is
we do we're chartered by state organiz a
state law to uh put together a a
committee which has 20 members on it and
these members would be familiar to you
names like the BFW the American Legion
all of the services are represented as
well I represent the air and space
forces Association on this committee one
of the things we do is we look at all
the bills that are coming before the
legislature and we signal out the ones
that we think have better impact and
then I come as the legislative chair and
I tell you what we've excited about that
particular bill so with that all in mind
I am the Messenger okay about what I'm
about to tell you um art we have opposed
this bill since the first one came out
in 2018 we opposed it in 2018 we oppos
it again in in
2020 and our principal argument from our
members has always been that the the
symbol that that that we want on our
coffins the symbol that talks about our
Services is the American flag uh the
honor and remember folks I don't really
have anything against them although you
know I I do take exception maybe a
little bit in paragraph two where it
says they're a National Organization
these folks are a commercial concern
they make money off of these flags so
while they may have good intentions and
I I we we know that they do somebody
makes money for that Corporation off of
this and it's not like a National
Organization like you know like the like
the VFW or the American Legion it's it's
a it's a commercial uh
concern and so when you have a bill like
this that that b basically mandates that
we're going to and we already have one
for the for the veteran cator they're
good there we're going to have to
procure one for the State House
according to this bill uh to grow up
there and so somebody's going to
essentially Soul Source award this kind
of government contract Small Potatoes
though it may be you know they're
they're giving that this to these folks
so that that has been some of the
argument some of our some of our
positions have softened over time
unfortunately and I asked them twice
they said this is not one of those ones
that we that that we're ready to sop it
our position on now like like Colonel
Perry said if this bill goes forward
life goes
on we'll all we'll all you know salute
smartly and move on we're all military
folks that's concludes by testimony
unless anybody has any questions for me
about why we came to the conclusions
that we did thank you are there any
questions from the
committee thank you much and I build no
I I I I have no ill will towards anybody
that's is supporter of this bill one of
my one of my students I was a junior RTC
instructor his name was Captain Ryan
fuff was the last air casualty of the G
for died in an airplane crash in
February of 2020 right before covid so I
I understand where these people are
coming from thank you yes
ma'am uh I'd like to call Mark deot to
I'm sorry if I mispronounced
that you are in support of the bill and
you have written down three to four
minutes for your testimony yes Madam
chair thank you thank you madam chairman
uh my name is Mark tooto I'm a gold star
father and I've worked with honor and
remember for many years we lost our son
Army specialist Mark Paul deotto on
January 29th 2010 in wak Province
Afghanistan uh my wife Nancy and I live
in Thornton and I thank you for this
opportunity to uh speak to you in
support of House Bill
honor and remember Incorporated is a
national
501c3 nonprofit
organization which coordinates
activities and ceremonies across the
country to honor and remember every
American Fallen service member and
recognize the enduring sacrifice of
every family who has lost a hero in
service to our country there are many
ways that the organization seek to carry
out this very important
Mission first and foremost the group
funds and presents honor and remember
Flags to family members who have lost
loved ones in service to our nation
families of any service member who has
died under any circumstances whether
it's direct combat training or as a
result of
service in any conflict from the
Revolutionary War to the present day are
eligible to receive a flag honor and
remember here in New Hampshire has
recognized and continues to recognize
service members from World War II Korea
Vietnam the Cold War and the global war
on terrorism as an example are the uh
the two crafts Brothers uh from
Manchester uh the brothers were both UNH
graduates and they were captains in the
United States Army during World War II
the brothers were killed a few weeks
apart in the European theater um and we
presented honor and remember flags for
each of the captains uh to their sister
uh who's the only remaining direct
relative of
them and our F our gold star family
members and volunteers are actively
seeking out the families of others to
honor and in this special way we feel
that it is critical to let these
families know that the service of their
loved one and their personal ongoing
sacrifice is not and will not be
forgotten as has been stated we have
submitted bills in the past and um you
may hear that in the past uh it's been
said that our organization wants to
somehow replace the American flag and
that we want the honor remember flag to
drape the coffins of returning Heroes I
assure you nothing could be further from
the truth we want the honor and remember
flag to be a way to recognize gold star
families for their sacrifice and to keep
the memory of their loved ones alive our
family has received several American
flags to honor our son one uh flew over
Ford operating base nun in wardak
Province the place where Mark was killed
others uh another one flew over his
unit's headquarters at BAM Air Base in
Afghanistan and the final and most
special one was the one that covered his
casket these three flags are memorials
to Mark and our family has decided that
they will never be flown again we also
have an honor and remember flag similar
to the ones you the one you were shown
that has his name on it it flies
regularly at our house and we take it to
the New Hampshire Run for the Fallen
every year we show it to children at the
Waterville Valley Elementary School when
we talk to them about Mark and others
who have served and sacrificed for our
country this is our way of sharing our
son with others outside of our home this
is a sort of emblem and purpose that we
are asking you to support with this bill
we remember to maintain the link with
Mark Paul as a nation we remember our
war dead to help build an appreciation
for what we have and to recognize the
sacrifice of service that members who
have died and their families have made
for our country we need to teach the
majority of our country about the
willingness to serve serve and the
sacrifice it takes to maintain the
sovereignty of our nation and to protect
our way of life no loss of a service
member is insignificant and we need to
make sure that everyone in New Hampshire
is aware of the debt that they owe to
those who have sacrificed thank you for
considering this
legislation and um I'm available to take
questions if you have any thank you very
much for your testimony representative
wall thank you for your testimony my
deepest sympathy to you and your family
for your loss um was your son's funeral
a military funeral yes it was um I just
wonder and I have no opinion one way or
the other um with my folks my parents
were both military and they had military
funerals as well um the American flag
was on their caskets that's correct um
you said that this remember flag was on
your son's casket no no I'm saying that
that is not what we want our our son had
an American flag on his casket and it is
fully my intention as a as a veteran
myself I I would want I I would not want
it to be any different than that okay
thank you I was just wondering if I
misheard if it was the protocol or what
right um and again I'm so sorry thank
you thank
you are there any other
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you madam
chair I'd like to call up Andy Cruz
who's in support of the
bill and you have here you need five
minutes for your testimony I'll be
quicker than that thank
you thank you members of the committee
um I am here um testifying in support of
this bill um I am a marine veteran
Desert Shield Desert Storm I am a
lifetime member M of the
VFW um I'm a part of the American Legion
I have been very active in veteran
services and causes throughout State of
New Hampshire I was one of the founding
members of veterans count uh who works
with Easter Seals and I am now a board
member and founder of swim with a
mission swim with a mission um if you're
not familiar with it it's 501c3 we have
partnered with the state recently on the
Gopher um and working with the state and
actually processing those grants for
veteran organizations We have basically
as an organization helped fund those
veteran services that are in need um and
in our state there there's a great need
to it as a population we actually have a
higher population per capita than most
states of veteran services uh we take a
lot of pride in that this in the state
and we have worked very hard to become
one of the most veteran friendly states
in the country most recently with
Franklin and and working on that Center
which is going to be be a um a huge win
for our state in attracting military
families which I think provides great
Services um they're great workers
they're great families great
constituents for our state and we want
to continue to be veteran friendly but
there's nothing I could say we could do
more than honoring the gold star
families you know for veterans who have
passed you know they've gone gone on and
they paid the ultimate sacrifice but
these families live on and they have
that pain and suffering on a daily basis
they come to our events we carry every
one of our events we have a memory wall
that has a name of each one of our
following for the State of New Hampshire
and these families come out to be able
to see those names and remember their
individual their their child their
brother their sister and it gives them a
sense of purpose and I got to tell you
it's a great right now as they had
mentioned earlier a recruiting with it
being down with military service
I can't think of a better thing we could
do here at the state than to honor those
that have fallen because folks you know
you commend you because You' have
decided to serve the state and you serve
it willingly but freedom is not
free so I would appreciate yall support
on this Bill thank you and I'll open up
any questions thank you for your
testimony any
questions no questions thank you very
much I'd like to call up Geraldine
Duncan
who is in support of this bill and you
need two to three minutes for your
testimony thank
you thank you very much for having me
today um I'd like to start by giving you
a little background on my interactions
with Goldstar family members I'm a
military spouse of 40 plus years when um
our recent conflicts have happened my
husband was the New Hampshire Army
National Guard Chief of Staff so a lot
of times when we had losses in this
state um our faces were oftentimes the
first that family members saw we have
continued those relationships some going
on 20 years um and one of the things
that we have seen that brings Comfort to
our families is this flag my husband is
a West Point graduate
79 um a true patriot and flag etiquette
to him um he sees sometimes what has
been done to our flag and it often
brings HIM Tears so when I first
approached him with this honor and
remember flag he was like many others um
absolutely against it because we do have
an American flag and what that
symbolizes um is extremely important for
him he fought for that in combat in
Afghanistan um came home with um both
physical and and
um and non-physical wounds of war and
when we've talked about this he is in
full support of this flag because he
again has seen what it's done for our
family he again has taken a step back
and really looked into what we're asking
for um there are 27 states in the
country that have adopted this flag it
is clearly stated on any of their
material that they put out it will
always be sub subservient to any other
flag that you would fly to include the P
Mia flag to include any other flags
often times it's actually flown separate
on a different flag pole because it does
get messy right and as visual people we
just don't want stacking of so what
we're asking now is for five I think
it's five specific days
and often times again we've been doing
this for over two decades there's such
an outpour ing of Community Support when
we
lose um a military service member in any
way we lower the flags there are hours
and hours of waights when we attend
funerals there are lines of processions
and guess what most of that goes away
and the only thing that we hear from our
families is that their children their
loved ones their spouses are remembered
and this is just I feel a very small ask
for them to be able to be considered so
that the education can go out in
communities because when you see the
American flag everybody's thinking you
know again it's a symbol for all of us
but if you were to walk down your
neighborhood and see this beautiful flag
flying you might stop and if somebody's
out gardening ask them about it right
and they get to tell that story of their
loved on so um I I really implore that
you take the time and really look at
there's a way website that explains it
all um 27 States always subservient to
other stuff so there there had been for
many years and we have we're not giving
this we're not giving up um so we have
just you know kind of let people come up
with their own ideas of what it what the
purpose is and the purpose really is to
give back to those families who have
given that ultimate
sacrifice thank you very much for your
testimony will you take questions yep
there any questions from the committee
yes uh representative wall thank you
thank you for telling us that 27 states
have adopted this I I've been wondering
that um do they those States uh have the
same requirements that this bill is
asking no it it's a different
legislation some of them fly it at all
times you know so it's different per per
state and good enough thank you so much
thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very much
you I would like to call up
representative
groto welcome to legislative
Administration thank you so much I'm
representative Jackie Gro I'm here
representing Rockingham 24 which are the
towns of Ry and
Greenland Blake Maron whose name is on
that flag would have been one of my
constituents because his mother is a
constituent of mine and she brought this
bill this idea to my attention and
that's why I co-sponsored the
bill we have in above our Capital an
American flag and underneath that
American flag is a p Mia flag and that
flag flies daily to remind us all of
those that are missing in action or
prisoners of
war in that are in the
military this bill is not very
complicated it only asks that we fly the
honor and remember flag 5 days a week
underneath the state
flag and if the cost of the flag is an
issue I can assure you I'll be glad to
provide it to the state as a
gift the flag to me completes the
story when someone's missing an
action and they've been
found that family receives a gold
star and that to me closes the chapter
for that family and for that person
however those individuals live forever
in our hearts and should be remembered
and should be armored with this flag on
those five days a week above the state
capital thank
you will you take any questions
absolutely thank you you any questions
from the
committee and you said um it's five days
a year correct I'm so did I say five
days a week I'm so sorry it's five days
a year thank you yes thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you I'd like to call up uh Jim
Moody who um is in support of this bill
and you have three minutes for your
testimony yes ma'am thank
you
thank you for allowing me to testify my
name is Jim Moody um I live in hookit I
am a retired Army National Guard uh
member uh 31 years of service uh my
sister and brother-in-law are both gold
star parents they lost their son to
suicide after returning from Iraq um as
was mentioned the honor and remember
flag does not replace any flag uh and
that was never the intent it recognizes
the sacrifice made on behalf of our
country um I have various folded Flags
in in my house uh I have one that was
flown over the state capital here uh
that I was given up upon my retirement I
also have uh flags that were uh draped
my both my parents uh coffins who both
served in the Army unless you come into
my house you have no idea what those
flags represent uh you see a folded flag
but unless I tell you specifically what
it is for you will never know my sister
and brother-in-law are the same way they
have an honor and remember flag and they
just moved into a new house and as soon
as their flag pole is up that flag will
will fly proudly below the US flag um
but right now they have a folded flag
for their son Derek in their house but
who sees that besides them nobody knows
of their sacrifice unless you personally
know my sister and brother-in-law uh the
honor and remember flag is an outward
symbol of a family sacrifice so everyone
can see and understand the cost of
freedom I will mention two things uh
that one that Mark tooto mentioned the
Run for the fallen and one that Andy
Cruz just mentioned about um the
recruiting wos um for our military
across the board um Mark mentioned the
Run for the Fallen that is held every
year to recognize those um from 2018 on
was basically the from any service
member that was lost in the global war
on terror either directly through
training or suicide um this Year my
sister and brother-in-law went to the um
Run for the Fallen uh in New Hampshire
and besides the immediate family members
there and the runners there was no one
else no one else remembered their
sacrifice this is definitely a way where
five times a year as a minimum the state
of New Hampshire can recognize those
that have served our country and given
their lives for our freedom thank you
thank you for your testimony will you
take questions yes ma'am any questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you and I'd like to call up
Patty cluder who's in support of this
bill um you have written down 15 minutes
for your testimony it'll probably be
less than that but I was just okay thank
you very much I've never been to one of
these so well welcome with me welcome to
legislative
Administration well thank you very much
um my name is Patty cluer my son was
specialist Shawn Michael FL
year May May 19th
2019 my son took his life while
serving I have received a flag from
honor and
remember and I look at it this way this
is my Outlook on on this whole
situation these servicemen and women die
by just die in honor of our country
every
day they sign a blank
check for their
sacrifice and then they cash it with
their
lives why shouldn't we have the chance
to honor
them and honor the sacrifice that they
make every day of their
lives thank you and I'm opened up with
questions
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from the
committee see none thank
you and the last person uh
Jared M
mow
Mar welcome to legislative
Administration thank you for having me
uh my name is Jared mosu um try to get
through this
ah nine years ago today we lost my
cousin Blake he's the name that was on
the flag that you saw
earlier um I have a quick note that I'd
like to read for you
guys uh this is written uh by my my
youngest son who was uh named after
Blake my name is Noah Blake Mau when I'm
at my niece's house we put out a flag
every day I always asked put the put out
the Blake flag because it reminds me of
Blake
and that's my name too I'm only years
old but I know it's important to
remember we salute the flags and say
good morning
Blake lots of people see the flags and I
think it's good and I feel
proud my aunt flies this flag on her own
every Sunday she flies the American flag
every
day I have a flag in my house that's
folded up that was carried by Blake on
his first tour in Afghanistan
I know my brother has a flag from him as
well it means a lot for our family to
see this flag fly whether it's Blake's
flag at my aunt's house or one that
flies over the stay house and we hope
that it
will I've had multiple opportunities to
talk to people who will walk by my
aunt's house and they
ask what is that flag and and what's it
for because they don't know and it
provides an opportunity to have that
conversation so that people do
understand that our members our military
members are sacrificing themselves for
us for our freedoms so that we can go
about our
lives in
comfort and knowing
that they will not be forgotten and it
just allows us another way to remember
them and make sure that their memory
stays alive
forever there's I I don't know exactly
the uh no the uh best phrasing for this
but when someone dies they die
twice the day they die when their soul
leaves their
body and the second death is the day
that someone's name is said for the last
time this allows us another way to make
sure that never happens
regardless of when someone served or
when they
passed uh thank you if you have any
questions I can the Happy Day answer
thank you for your testimony are there
any
questions see no questions thank you
very much thank
you and I don't have any more pink cards
so I'm going to close the hearing for HB
and it is 20:5 and I'm going to open up
the public hearing for HB
and I will call the prime sponsor rep
Gallagher welcome to legislative
Administration
representative uh hi so I'm Eric
gallager
representative for maram County District
20 which is conquered Ward six um and um
well I've actually got two bills here
today but I guess um the starting with
1096 um enabling the State House fit
Center to sell state symbols that may
have intellectual property rights
holders so
basically
um where this idea came from was uh just
in our previous term I believe we had a
bill to
um add an additional state song to our
list of um State songs
um
and I I believe that what um some of the
points raised during that debate were oh
well
we have a lot how um how many is that it
was like 10 or something and I was
thinking oh hey that sounds like the
perfect um length of an album um and
so I decided to go ask the um gift shop
if they could uh
sell an album of all of our St songs and
um they said they weren't really quite
sure
um because of the some some of them have
um intellectual property rights attached
to them that
um that they weren't quite sure how to
handle um so this is basically just to
clarify that
situation um yeah it's
um so yeah we have a big state symbol
section of
um so it mentions such as State Songs it
would presumably also apply to um
other state symbols with um like I I
think there's um state or state poems or
something too that this might also apply
to um
so
um yeah it's a pretty simple Bild just
four lines uh so I'll take any questions
now thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions from
the
committee R Pearson thank you madam
chair representative Gallagher thank you
for coming today and
presenting this legislation to the
committee uh you mentioned a state song
as an example um and some other state
symbols are are you aware that in most
cases when those are adopted the creator
of those
surrenders their rights to those to the
state as part of that
process um if that's the case then
that's good to hear
um the thing is um that
um well it's just a point that there
hasn't really been much Clarity on like
I remember it coming up um in the
previous debate we had about adopting a
new state song was about the
intellectual property rights and then
also um just for figuring out why we
weren't already doing this it's just
because there was some uncertainty so um
yeah
if um if they already can then um if
this is already handled then that's um
that's good to hear um but I just think
some additional Clarity would be useful
to make sure it's
specified
explicitly thank you very much uh
representative
mcarter thank you madam chair um thank
you for coming today uh representative
Gallagher I did have um I'll be at a
brief description with Virginia from the
gift uh the gift shop today uh last week
maybe I think it was uh she did say she
was going to come today is she here yeah
I see her in the audience um I'd be
interested if if you can um listen to
her her explanation about um the
intellectual property type of
arrangement and with it with its uh
state symbols being having to have
approval from the Secretary of State's
office because they're almost not
copyrighted but a similar type of U
protection on those um on those symbols
so I I wonder if youve if you've thought
about maybe speaking with the secret of
State's office as well um I I mean yes I
or uh I talked with uh Virginia myself
when um preparing this bill um I don't
think she mentioned anything about the
Secretary of State's office at the time
um but um having that additional lead is
useful and um yeah if uh I mean well
Virginia is going to speak after you so
she can probably speak to that I I was
just looking to see if there's anyone
from the Secretary of State's office and
the audience um but I don't recognize
anyone
so thank you is there any more questions
all right thank you very much are you
rep ball are you all
set I was just going to say that paton's
registered with the US patent office in
Washington
thank you for your testimony and I'd
like to call uh Virginia
Drew who signed in uh to oppose this
bill welcome to legislative
Administration for the record it's
Virginia drew the State House Visitors
Center Director um I will say I've been
the in The Visitor Center for over 20
years I appreciate representative
Gallagher's intent to try to make things
easier and um hold other items in the
visitor center but I did discourage that
this legislation I didn't think was
necessary I still feel that I will do
clarification the Secretary of State
holds the authority over the state seal
and in The Visitor Center we have
approval to have certain items with the
state seal anything else um we we
basically stick to very general items in
the visitor center and thank you thank
you very much for your testimony will
you take questions yes any questions
from the
committee R Pearson I'd be lost in this
incredible opportunity to have you on
the other side of a
microphone so um but in the sense that
the visitor center does sell a
product to the public and to the folks
that do come to this this very very
ancient State
House have you found the desire for
people to come and purchase something
that you can't sell that would fall that
would fall under the intent of what
we're doing here no it hasn't come
before and I did mention that there are
a lot of items that our state symbols
that would not be appropriate to carry
in a visitor center such as pumpkin
spiders potato for the dairy
folks any other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank you and seeing no other
pink cards for HB 1096 I'm going to
close the
hearing
for
May is a little past 2:15 I'm going to
open up the public hearing for HB
1367 and uh we have uh the prime sponsor
rep gall back on the hot seat yep um hi
so yeah again I'm representative Eric
Galler representing May County District
20 which is conquered W 6 um I'm here
now to introduce House Bill 1367
relative to establishing immunity for
certain testimony in public legislative
hearings so
um yeah as
legislators uh basically what we do here
is we make determinations we make laws
about things about um what we think
should be legal or illegal and um when
we do that we have this process where we
have hearings like this one to discuss
the um activity in question and we're
actually kind of unique in New Hampshire
here and that we have open public
hearings where anyone can come
testify um and I think that's a good
thing I think being able to hear from as
many people as possible um
is um a great opportunity that we have
before us
um
so sometimes when I've been um trying
trying
to uh convince people to um come testify
about
something uh
they've expressed um some concern that
their testimony could get them in
trouble somehow so
um
uh I have introduced this bill to um
basically try to
um in um improve the um amount and
veracity of the testimony we receive in
hearings like this
um
uh um yeah I think we should be making
our decisions with all the relevant
information available um especially from
the people in question who
bills would affect
um
so
um yeah about this bill um so it's
neutral um in terms of it's not
necessarily pro- legalizing things or
Pro or anti- legalizing things um the S
it would protect both kinds of testimony
like both people saying oh this illegal
activity caused a lot of harm to me and
I believe it should be restricted
further or um also the testimony of oh
this illegal activity is actually
harmless and should be
legalized
um so uh I discussed this
um I discussed this legislation with the
ACLU um one concern they said I might
face would be like oh well um yeah
people might ask oh well couldn't
someone take advantage of this to uh get
away with murder or some other heinous
crime or something and
so um I took that feedback and um yeah
put in uh redraft request which is
reflected in the bill um to add the um
relevance Criterion um the part where it
says the order of immunity shall be
restricted only to cover testimony
concerning potential criminal conduct
related to the statute that is the
subject of the
hearing um so yeah for example with
um
for this bill um HB
1367 the statute in question is R RSA
14 uh section 14 C so um it would be
only testimony related to um that
portion that would be covered um
so and also um the chair has
to this is um a decision being made
by the chair of whether or not to Grant
this or not um so I I personally think
um those two factors um the relevance
Criterion and the fact that the chair
has to grant grant it are ought to be
enough of a safeguard but um if the
committee would like to add additional
safeguards like say maybe distinguishing
between violent and non-violent crimes
or maybe distinguishing between
misdemeanors and felonies or certain
classes of
misdemeanor um I'd be open to that too
um the only reason I didn't do that
myself is because um I wasn't quite sure
how how
to go about um wording it
specifically
um
so yeah uh I I think this bill is
consistent
with um existing principles of law we've
got the um we've got the Fifth Amendment
right against
self-incrimination that implies it in uh
Court proceedings I think that um we
should make sure to clarify that um
it uh applies in legislative hearings
too um so that way we can uh get the um
best testimony with which to make the
best decisions about the bills we
consider and I'll take questions now
thank you for your testimony R Pearson
thank you madam chair representative
gallager um are you aware that when you
testify in front of a house committee
you are you are not only are you not
under subpoena but you're not under oath
so therefore no
one is ever required sitting in that
seat to answer a question that's brought
before him by a house
committee um well
so yes that's true but um sometimes the
um well there there can still be kind of
a chilling effect in the first place of
somebody who thinks thinks that
um who thinks that they might be put in
a sort of situation where that comes up
um it it's not
um it it's more about being able to make
it easier to convince people that it's
safe for them to
testify um
and
um yeah I I I think um
give so the the current yeah the current
way um to do that would be just to not
answer a question um I think it would be
better if people could answer the
question um and provide the full
information um rather than having to go
the not answering the question route
just um so we can get the uh full
information thank you are there any
other questions rip
tuny thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so your bill is
proposing that an individual sitting his
chair that in most cases probably has no
legal experience
whatsoever is going to make a decision
as to
immunity for uh somebody
testifying
um well I
mean you know we're the the fact that
we're not
lawyers we we still make laws about this
in the first um anyways um I I don't see
how the fact that uh we're not
lawyers uh really would restrict the
decision to Grant immunity any more than
it would to make the law in the first
place you're right we make laws here and
many times they get struck down by
lawyers in the Supreme Court uh or a
lower court first then the Supreme Court
um what you're proposing would Grant
folks to come up here and say okay uh um
I know uh cannabis helps medically but
it also helps my mood so that's why I
smoke it even though that's
illegal um yeah I think that it would be
useful to hear from people right but
they're breaking a law yeah that
currently is on the
books and according to this
representative shien would be able to
say you have blanket Immunity on or
you'd have immunity for your testimony
and she's not a lawyer knowing where
does this fit in the pecking
order uh for immunity and for the
law
um well so yeah
it what so one one other thing to
mention is um the immunity applies
specifically to um the their
testimony um that they're providing so
um yeah it it's not like it's not like a
blanket immunity it just means that
their testimony specifically that
they're providing here for the purposes
of us being able to decide how we want
to vote on things um can't be used
against
them representative wall
thank you madam chairman thank you for
your testimony um I've been here a long
time and I served about 30 some odd
years on the Judiciary Committee we
dealt with some very very sensitive
issues and people could have gotten into
some kind of problems as you're
suggesting but usually when people
testify they're testifying purely on the
facts and not on their behavior or
something like that um we do have with
our right to no law specific times when
we can go into non-public session I've
never known a committee in this house to
do that except the Ethics
Committee and I can't imagine a
committee where immunity would be
necessary except on something like the
Ethics Committee and again we have the
right to no law which is very specific
in terms of when we can offer people the
chance to go into to nonpublic session
and not feel the uh judgment or concerns
of others are you aware of
that
um yes I uh I am familiar with 91a and
that it has Provisions for um non-public
sessions um I was thinking more that um
uh I I I don't I don't think people
should have to be in private to be
honest with their testimony I think they
should be able to uh do that in public
as
well R
mcarter thank you madam chair so uh Reb
Gallagher you I can understand where
you're where you're I kind of almost
understand where you're coming from with
this
however Let's uh you could certainly
explore many different types of subject
matter for uh statute building that we
do here every time we're in session um
in a in a meeting let's say for example
somebody wants to put forth a bill for
oh I don't know a brothel they're legal
in New Hampshire that's what the intent
of the bill is um does that make it what
the behavior is legal now no so you're
going to want to have people come in and
uh testify to how wonderful it will be
if we have brothel all over the state we
already do it we just you don't know
about it yet or it's under the radar you
you're going to have people coming in to
uh to try to sell the idea why wouldn't
they just come and sell in
hyperbole uh wouldn't it be nice if
instead of saying we already do this
it's the same they're giving the same
information they're not admitting to
anything they're not saying they don't
either though uh so where does the
social hierarchy start you're looking to
not uh have them held com uh
criminally uh uh liable for for their
testimony but that doesn't remove the
social consequence or perhaps employment
consequence should their boss be
watching the YouTube stream of this
committee it doesn't remove any of the
other a stigmatic one uh you know that
it it it just removes enforcement's
ability to uh utilize that in a fashion
that's already designed in statute so I
think it's more of a package what you're
trying to accomplish here than just
removing you know the the criminal
aspect of this am I am I incorrect
um I
mean I think the criminal aspect is
pretty much the only thing we can modify
through the law the rest of the stuff
like cultural stigmas and stuff aren't
really that that's not the the law isn't
the right Avenue to be addressing those
sorts of things that that would be like
we just have to convince people not to
um stigmatize people who um who decide
they want to be honest and make
confessions about um things that they've
done
rip oh follow up
yeah
so uh being the structure of a
legislature that we are wouldn't you
think that um it might be more of a a a
reasonable Avenue for someone uh this uh
this um fictitious person that we're
talking about in this circumstance they
go to their representative and propose
something hey why don't we why don't you
get out there and make this legal right
and then you being the representative
maybe not you specifically the mayor or
whomever uh we're supposed to go and
advocate for the for the proposition or
the proposal and try to get Buy in from
the other legislators so that doesn't
necessarily mean that person has to come
and testify for something that may be
deemed as a criminal activity uh it's
it's the way the the representative
comes in and makes the proposal in hyper
pathetical terms I I just don't see
where this legislation is is needed at
this point well so yes I um you could
send someone else to testify on your
behalf but um I think secondhand
testimony is never really quite as good
as firsthand testimony like we're we're
all familiar with the game of telephone
here right you know where you pass a
message along between a a bunch of
different people and um get a different
result at the end uh I think I think um
that's something
to um worth um addressing is to try to
avoid the information loss that uh comes
with having to send someone else to
testify for
you rep ning
Wong hey just wanted to ask if um this
is an issue you've run in a lot and if
it has happened more recently since
we've started streaming on the
internet um I mean this is only my
second term in office so I don't think
I've
really been here long enough to
um be able to make any sort of time
scale
comparisons
um but
um yeah it it it is something that I
have encountered when talking with
constituents or members of interest
groups who um might be interested in
testifying any other questions yeah
thank you madam chair uh on at the end
of this you
specifically address criminal
cases you do not mention civil cases and
was that a
consideration that you gave when you
drafted this or is was that an oversight
to leave the Civil side of the law out
of
this
um I I I think criminal cases are my
primary concern
um
I yeah that's that's just all how all
how I'm going to answer it I just think
that cases are my primary concern
here seeing no other questions thank you
very much for your testimony
yep ref Gallagher do you have written
testimony you can
submit um not be um not Beyond um I sent
well I sent an email to the committee
when we were talking about
um when we were talking about like the
scheduling for today that included some
R testimony but I don't have any
additional anything beyond that though
thank
you and the last pink card for HB 1367
Trisha
nallu
sorry and then you're in support of this
bill
welcome oh there we go
good
afternoon my name is Trisha naalu I'm
here representing myself and my
community throughout my career I have
used an alias and in fact most of the
community that I work with uses another
name for safety
precautions I am the founder of erotic
laborers Alliance of New England we
offer resources to consensual adults
engaged in sex work we are also an
anti-trafficking
group granting immunity when giving
testimony for certain community members
concerning possible criminal conduct
would increase their sense of safety
when coming forward and it would
encourage testimony of their lived
experience these marginalized voices of
both consenting adults and trafficking
survivors who face violence
discrimination
criminalization deserve to participate
in
democracy they deserve to feel
safe when doing so and be granted
immunity a good example would be a human
trafficking Survivor that wants to talk
about her personal experience about
trafficking but in doing so would be
admitting criminal activities such as
prostitution we can all agree that we
want to hear real life testimony and
that we should not be sending the police
after her to make a prostitution arrest
similarly a person who wants to talk
about their drug addiction struggles in
a drug policy hearing perhaps should not
be targeted or criminalized
afterwards it was here at this state
house where I first outed
myself I went on record with my real
name as an erotic
laborer we worked a lot with bipartisan
support and we passed a healthcare Bill
of Rights and an immunity from arrest or
prosecution for prostitution Bill we
worked with law enforcement then and we
would gladly work with law enforcement
any other
time since then I had a stalker sending
mail to my house knowing exactly where I
live that was very frightening and I
cannot say without certainty that using
my real name publicly here at the State
House did not contribute to
that regardless of My Chosen profession
or the various professions of the
marginalized community of erotic
laborers in New
Hampshire our community would like to be
granted some sort of immunity when we're
sharing our
voices we would like to avoid possibly
being targeted for harassment or
criminalization and that's why we
support this today I'm open to any
questions you might have thank you for
your testimony are there any questions
from the
committee seeing no questions thank you
very much thank you thank you for your
time oh um the testimony that you read
can you send that to our committee yes
or do you have printed copies today oh I
ran out of ink but I can email it that
would be great thank you very much all
right
thanks and seeing no other pink cards
I'm going to close the hearing for HB
1367 and that ends our agenda for
today Madam chair when are we meeting
again do we have a date on the
calendar this is tentative it's not set
in stone yet but I believe we're going
to meet again on the
31st uh stay tuned for the exact
time uh well we have other bills in our
committee that will prob yeah correct
correct